bonjour à tous merci de nous retrouver
sur Public Sénat à suivre ce matin sur
notre antenne un débat sur le
rayonnement culturel de la France à
travers le monde hier dans l'hémicycle
du Sénat certains sénateurs ont fait
part de leur inquiétude parmi eux la
centriste Catherine main de sali qui
estime que la diffusion massive de la
culture nord-américaine met d'une
certaine manière en péril notre identité
nationale mais aussi européenne alors
quelles sont les solutions proposées par
les sénateurs pour contrer cette
tendance pour le savoir direction
l'hémicycle bonne matinée à tous
monsieur le ministre mes chers collègues
dans mon rapport d'information présenté
au Sénat en
2004 intitulé pour une nouvelle
stratégie de l'action cultur sur
l'extérieur de la France de l'exception
à l'influence je mesurai le poids des
attentes envers l'autorité et la
puissance publique attente insatisfaite
qui générait
l'immobilisme le déclin de la France se
nourrit d'abord et c'est bien connu de
conservatis et autres corporatis en 2010
rapporteur pour avis de la loi sur
l'action extérieur de l'État je faisais
le constat de la dispersion des
différents opérateurs de la diplomatie
culturel trop nombreux pour être
efficace problème auquel il était urgent
de remédier c'est à la suite de
l'adoption de cette loi que trois
établissements publics l'Institut
français dont j'ai obtenu l'appellation
de haute lutte Campus France et France
expertise internationale ont vu le jour
et ont concentré chacun dans son domaine
différentes activités relatives à
l'action culturelle extérieure je me
réjouis ainsi de l'organisation de ce
débat sur les enjeux du rayonnement
culturel de la France et je remercie le
groupe um du Sénat pour cette
initiative lors de votre récente
intervention monsieur le ministre à
l'École normale supérieure la France sur
le thème de la France une puissance
d'influence vous avez souligné
l'importance du défi éducatif et
culturel de notre pays dans un monde
complexe en constante évolution enjeu
décisif pour notre croissance économique
et notre influence diplomatique
la compétition est rude t le domaine de
l'éducation que dans l'apprentissage de
la langue française et la diffusion de
notre culture si notre pays a largement
perdu l'influence qu'il exerçait au 19e
siècle face à la concurrence des
États-Unis et maintenant des pays
émergents la France a néanmoins des
atouts considérables pour assurer son
rayonnement dans le monde son histoire
ses musées de renommée international sa
création artistique ses école et bien
évidemment la langue française qui reste
parlée par plus de 220 millions de
personnes dans le monde pour développer
notre influence nous avons des
instruments de qualité dont nous devons
ici vanter les performances face à ceux
de nos compétiteurs tel le British
Council pour le Royaume-Uni le gut
Institute pour l'Allemagne le cercle
servantè pour l'Espagne ou les Instituts
Confucius pour la Chine qui se
multiplient sur tous les continents
ces instruments dont nous pouvons être
fiers sont l'Institut français présidé
par un homme de grande culture
universitaire et ancien ministre
monsieur Xavier D'cos et le non moins
remarquable réseau des Alliances
françaises près d'un millier dans le
monde que je visite à chacun de mes
déplacements à
l'étranger n'oublions pas non plus
Campus France l'Agence pour
l'enseignement français à l'étranger
réseau de plus de 500 établissements
scolaires et la Mission laïque française
que nombre de pays nous envie
j'évoquerai enfin notre présence en
matière d'audiovisuel extérieur avec TV5
Monde France 24 et sa diffusion
trilingue français anglais arabe Radio
France Internationale et son rayonnement
multilingue le premier vecteur
d'influence culturelle monsieur le
ministre est l'Institut français la loi
du 27 juillet 2010 a conduit à mettre en
place un appareil législatif et
réglementaire complet conférence un
statut un mode de gestion et une
gouvernance compatible avec la LOLF et
comparable à celui du G Institute ou du
British Council le ministère des
Affaires étrangères de tutelle est
chargé de définir des stratégies
d'établir des priorité politique le
pilotage opérationnel du réseau est
confié à l'Institut français avec des
objectifs précis l'expérimentation en
cours a déjà contribué à démontrer dans
les 12 premiers pays concernés la
cohérence d'une architecture dans
laquelle chacun trouve son rôle en moins
de 2 ans la modernisation des modes de
gestion a été majeure alors que 10 ans
plus tôt le réseau culturel faisait
figure de mauvais élèves à Beris passage
à une norme comptable plus efficace mise
en place d'une nomenclature budgétaire
partagée entre l'Institut Français et
les 12 pays
d'expérimentation mise en place de
logiciels commun formation intégrée des
gestionnaires et des
les conséquences positives concrètes et
concrètes pour les postes sont
importantes fongibilité des crédits et
souplesse de gestion flux financier plus
rapide possibilité d'accorder des
subventions jusqu'ici interdites par le
décret de
1976 à noter que cette dernière
disposition permet de recourir aux
instituts français pour mettre en œuvre
la coopération universitaire et
qu'aucune difficulté de gestion n'est
depuis àaru dans ce secteur de la même
manière les bureaux locaux de l'Institut
français verseront en 2012 près de 3
millions d'euros de bourse à des
étudiants ou à des universitaires
étrangers axe fort de la politique
française
d'attractivité quelles que soient les
décisions prises les avancées ayant
conduit un opérateur public de l'État
gérer des représentations pilotes à
l'étranger devrait être maintenant
appliqué à l'ensemble du réseau pour
mémoire l'Agence française pour le
développement international des
entreprises uifance a également créé une
soixantaine de bureaux entre 2006 et
2009 mais l'ensemble des recettes est
perçu auprès des entreprises à Paris les
postes se contentant de gérer des
budgets
limités de fonctionnement autre avancée
notoire la mutualisation des processus
professionnels l'Institut français a pu
bénéficier d'une identité partagée avec
le réseau la fusion des services de de
coopération et d'action culturelle les
skac avec les établissements à autonomie
financière a entraîné la création
d'établissement à partir de 2009 et
l'appellation institut français s'est
généralisé dès 2010 renforçant la notion
d'appartenance à un réseau en effet le
partage d'une marque unique a été le
début d'un travail de mutualisation des
outils et de partage des bonnes
pratiques créatrice d'économie d'échelle
entre membres du réseau mise en place
d'outils numérique d'une culture tech
plateforme de produits culturels en
ligne et cetera le ciment de la
formation a par ailleurs été fondamental
pour appuyer ce processus quelques 1300
agents ont été formés en 2012 dont près
de la moitié en personnel recruté
localement toutes les formes de
mutualisation ont été encouragé et
l'Institut français avec ses ateliers
d'été a rempli un rôle essentiel de
modernisation et de
cohésion sur ce point de la profession
de la professionnalisation axe fort de
la loi de 2010 les acquis doivent être
poursuivis préparation retour notamment
par l'élaboration de passerell
professionnel avec les structures
d'origine mobilité professionnelle entre
le réseau et l'Institut la réforme
connaîtra monsieur le ministre une
réussite durable si les personnels
exerçant des responsabilité sont
accompagné dans leur progression de
carrière par l'État
employeur localement la création des
conseils d'orientation stratégique sous
la présidence de l'ambassadeur a été
compatible avec la LOLF et efficace la
fonction de pil de pilotage
stratégique cadre en outre avec le rôle
d'animation et de coordination des chefs
de poste sans être décisionnaire ces
conseils d'orientation stratégique
prennent en compte les réalités du
terrain et permettent de mener des
réflexions sur des stratégies ou des
priorités régionales en accord avec les
ambassadeurs de plus un élargissement
des compétences géographiques fait des
bureaux locaux de véritable relais
régionaux c'est un acquis considérable
pour la mise en œuvre de projets
multilatéraux la compétence nationale
des établissement à autonomie financière
les privés d'une participation pour
l'élaboration de projets r des
programmes adaptés seront ainsi
organisés notamment au Chili en Serbie
et à Singapour enfin en période de
contrainte budgétaire forte les
compétences régionales des bureaux
locaux de l'Institut français les
autorise à lever des fonds multilatéraux
et c'est nouveau dans le développement
futur du réseau comme le montre les
exemples du British Council qui gagne
tous les mois des appels d'offre
européen dans toutes les régions du
monde l'éducation monsieur le ministre
constitue le deuxè axe majeur de la
politique de rayonnement culturel de la
France dans ce domaine la France dispose
d'une force de frappe puissante un
réseau de
480 établissements homologués par
l'Éducation nationale dans 130 pays
cette homologation on garanti à la fois
la qualité et l'homogénéité au-delà du
service majeur qu'il rend à nos
compatriotes et à nos entreprises ce
réseau de l'Agence pour l'enseignement
français à l'étranger et de la Mission
laïque française est aussi un levier de
la politique d'influence car il permet
de contribuer à la formation des élites
étrangères il faut le souligner nos
établissements scolaires à l'étranger
constitue une autre grande valeur
culturelle ajoutée au-delà de
l'apprentissage simple du français en
permettant un travail en profondeur de
formation d' d'individus bilingues et
biculturels qui pourront être être à
leur tour des ambassadeurs de la culture
française nombre d'entre eux font
d'ailleurs de brillantes carrières dans
le secteur privé d'autres dans la haute
administration d'autres encore dans la
politique mais aussi dans le domaine des
sciences des arts et de la culture ils
constittuent tous des relais très
précieux pour notre pays autre élément
important au moment où des études
internationales mesurent et comparent
l'efficacité respective des systèmes
éducatifs le réseau des établissements
français à l'étranger offre une
vitrine de l'excellence éducative à la
française porteuse de valeurs reconnues
et recherché
laïcité
universalité humanisme développement de
l'esprit critique exigen intellectuell
le réseau s'attache aussi à promouvoir
la dimension plurilingue et
multiculturelle si essentielle
aujourd'hui
une table ronde a été organisée
récemment par la commission de la
culture de l'éducation et de la
communication au Sénat
elle réunissait les principaux acteurs
éducatifs et culturels elle a permis de
mieux saisir l'articulation entre les
différents
opérateurs de la langue et de la culture
française institut français Alliance
Française Mission laïque française
agence pour l'enseignement français à
l'étranger il est donc indispensable
aujourd'hui que des liens forts se
tissent entre tous ceux qui uvrent
finalement pour la même cause ainsi au
moment où nous souhaitons attirer plus
de jeunes vers les universités
françaises je pense que les chercheurs
dans nos instituts de recherche CNRS
EFEO IRD et cetera peuvent jouer un rôle
auprès des jeunes des lycées français en
leur montrant en quoi nos universités et
grandes écoles sont à la hauteur des
meilleures institutions nord-américaines
et dans le monde
les lycées français sont des pépinières
de futurs étudiants de choix pour nos
filières d'excellence dans
l'enseignement supérieur il faut aider
la EFE à préserver cette richesse
pédagogique et humaine et utiliser au
mieux ce magnifique outil de
développement que sont les lycées
français à l'étranger plus concrètement
nous devons continuer à aider
l'opérateur public à remplir sa mission
lafe organise la gestion de
l'intervention de la puissance publique
en cofinancement avec familles selon un
équilibre il faut le dire de plus en
plus difficile à atteindre mais qu'il
faut néanmoins préserver entre ces
différentes missions assurer la
continuité de la scolarité pour les
familles françaises par le maintien
prioritaire des bourses scolaires
contribuer au rayonnement de la culture
française en accueillant aussi des
élèves étrangers et participer aux
actions de coopération avec les systèmes
éducatifs étrangers c'est dans le
droitfil de cette coopération que j'ai
souhaité la tenue au Sénat le 29
novembre dernier des premières
Rencontres internationales de
l'enseignement bilingue
francophone événement qui a reçu
l'approbation de la Commission de la
culture de l'éducation et de la
communication du Sénat à laquelle j'ai
l'honneur d'appartenir S sont rencontrés
pour la première fois des chefs
d'établissement scolairire ayant reçu le
label France éducation accordé depuis
2012 à des établissements offrant à
leurs élèves un enseignement renforcé de
la
française dans plusieurs disciplines
cette marque est décernée par votre
ministère après avis d'une commission
consultative
interministérielle le programme est géré
par
lafe avec l'expertise scientifique du
Centre international d'études
pédagogiques à ont étroitement contribué
au succès de ces premières rencontres
l'Institut français le CEP l'Agence pour
l'enseignement français à l'étranger et
naturellement la direction de la
Politique culturel et du français de
votre ministère ces rencontres ont
permis à plus de 200 intervenants de
faire le point sur la situation de
l'enseignement du français dans les
filières biline d'excellence à travers
le monde et d'envisager les perspectives
offertes par le label France éducation
en terme de rayonnement de la langue et
de la culture française sur les cinq
continents en complémentarité faut-il le
rappeler et non pour se substituer au
dispositifs existants convaincu de
l'utilité de ces missions le Sénat se
réjouit que le ministre des Affaires
étrangères a choisi de préserver les
moyens d'évoluer à
laafe la Haute Assemblée
continuera d'accompagner cet opérateur
acteur référent d'une offre éducative
française singulière et
performante le trème axe de l'influence
française dans le monde monsieur le
ministre est constitué par l'action
audiovisuelle ex eur la France en ce
domaine est attendue dans un monde
globalisé et qui a tendance à
s'uniformiser son avis est respé bien
au-delà de son poids démographique ou de
sa puissance économique l'audiovisuel
français vers l'international occupe une
place à part à côté des grandes chaînes
anglo-saxonnes et des médias du monde
arabe alors de la mondialisation face à
des populations en quête de repère et de
compréhension il offre un regard
particulier sur l'information
internationale cette vision trouve son
entrage dans le monde francophone elle
est porteuse de valeurs universelle
attaché à la République qui nous
gouverne la liberté le pluralisme les
idées la confrontation des point de vue
l'indépendance de la presse la laïcité
l'égalité entre les hommes et les femmes
autant de principes qui reste à
promouvoir ou du moins à conforter dans
une partie importante du monde les
médias audiovisuel français constittu de
formidables caises de résonance c'est
c'est une situation peu connue en France
et nous pouvons regretter que nos
compatriotes sur le territoire national
n'ai pas une meilleure idée de l'action
extérieur de l'État au sein d'un monde
mondialisé ces médias sont également
pour nos 2,5 millions de compatriotes
expatriés un lien irremplaçable avec
notre pays face aux enjeux s trop
longtemps épuisé dans des réformes de
structure coûteuses et souvent mal
comprises ces dernières années deux
plans de départ volontaire non ciblé ont
touché 22 % des effectifs de
l'Audiovisuel Extérieur de la France une
fusion et un déménagement conjoint se
sont traduit par une profonde
désorganisation des entreprises le
pilotage fondé sur la recherche
exclusive d'une réduction des coûts à
marquer ses limites monsieur le ministre
l'État consacre pourtant moins de 9 % du
budget total de l'audiovisuel à son
action audiovisuelle extérieure comme
s'il en mésestimer finalement
l'importance au total ce sont un peu
plus de 300 millions d'euros chaque
année soit l'équivalent de la Deutch V
la moitié des budgets d'aljzira ou de
CNN 100 millions de moins que BBC World
c'est 300 millions sont répartis entre
France 24 trois chaînes d'information
continue en trois langues français arabe
RFI Radio France Internationale en 13
langues Monte Carlo d'Alia la radio
arabophone de l'Audiovisuel Extérieur de
la France et TV5 Monde chaîne
généraliste francophone sous-titré en
plus de 10 langues et qui réunit une
audience hebdomadaire de plus de 50
millions de téléspectateurs cet
investissement est néanmoins insuffisant
au regard des défis à relever
dans un contexte mondial très
concurrentiel médias de référence France
24 RFI et Monte Carlo doualia réalise
aussi des audiences en progression
constante RFI touche 40 millions
d'auditeurs Monte Carlo d'IA 8 millions
et fRANCE 24 est regardé par 45 million
de téléspectateurs en Tunisie la chaîne
en langue arabe devance légèrement
aljzira preuve que France24 c'est
répondre à l'envie de liberté et de
modernité des téléspectateurs de ce pays
toute chaîne confondu les environnements
nouveaux nouveaux médias de l'AEF ont
établi un record en janvier dernier avec
25 millions de visites les nouveaux
médias permettent de s'affranchir des
frontières territoriales pour toucher
les diaspora au-delà de leur pays
d'origine c'est vrai tant pour les
populations arabophones qu'aux
États-Unis avec 7 ou 8 millions
d'auditeurs autant en Amérique latine et
en Europe c'est vrai aussi pour d'autres
langues le site en vietnamien de RFI est
en terme de visite le deuxème site le
plus visité de la radio mondiale ces
études ne mesurent cependant pas
l'impact en terme d'influence de nos
médias l'information de RFI et France 24
en français est écouté ou regardé au
quotidien par les chefs d'État africain
de l'univers de la Francophonie la
version arabophone de France 24 et monte
carloudalia sont en passe de réussir le
même exploit dans le monde arabe enfin
depuis le 27 février France 24 en langue
anglaise est disponible au sein de
l'intégralité des bureaux du Département
d'État des États-Unis du département de
la Sécurité Intérieure et du département
de la Justice la qualité de la
couverture
éditoriale de l'Inter invention au Mali
a motivé cette décision il s'agit
aujourd'hui de conforter monsieur le
ministre ce qui existe et de développer
cette présence audiovisuelle
indispensable de la France hors de ses
frontières les objectifs de croissance
seront bien entendu fonction des moyens
que l'État mettra à la disposition de
son action audiovisuelle extérieur les
entraves à la présence sur certains
marchés sont multiples et souvent
coûteuses elles vont de la censure
politique au protectionnisme économique
à a une concurrence exponentielle
enendrant des coûts de distribution
parfois prohibitifs pour réussir des
virages doivent être négociés très
rapidement virage de la télévision
numérique terrestre l'Afrique va
basculer en TNT à partir de 2015 si
France 24 et TV5 Monde ne parviennent
pas à profiter de la TNT elles seront
fortement pénalisées et rapidement
marginalisé virage de la Haute
Définition là encore France24 comme TV5
Monde doivent bénéficier d'un
financement spécifique pour ne pas voir
se voir interdire demain l'accès à
certains marché l'objectif de notre
action audiovisuelle extérieure
et bien sûr d'être présent mondialement
au-delà des zones d'influence
traditionnelles de la France que sont
l'Afrique et le monde arabe en en
s'appuyant sur tous les levier d'action
existant et en jouant de la
complémentarité des médias nos médias
doivent enfin disposer d'un point
d'appui sur le territoire national il
n'est pas concevoable que France 24
seule chaîne d'information continue du
service public ne bénéficie pas d'une
fenêtre de diffusion sur la TNT qui doit
être une fenêtre ouverte sur le monde le
Grand Large si la France a un rôle à
jouer elle doit s'en donner les moyens
cela passe aussi par l'adhésion de la
communauté nationale à une France de
nouveaux territoires à conquérir en
matière culturelle et économique pour
ions nous dire en résumé et en
conclusion le monde change et nous
voulons changer avec lui pas si sûr les
Français en règle générale V vivent mal
la mondialisation ils disent leur
anxiété sondage après sondage la
question est pourtant de savoir si nous
voulons être des mondialisateurs ou des
mondialisés la réponse n'est pas encore
évidente au discours entretenu par des
élites démissionnaires convaincu que la
conduite d'une globalisation profitable
à défaut d'être heureuse se fait
uniquement en anglais nous n'avons pas
encore de réponse affirmé pour lutter
contre les rigidités françaises c'est
pourtant à ce prix que la recherche
d'une meilleure compétitivité pour notre
pays grâce à l'innovation et une
confiance en soi retrouvée est
indissociable de la volonté de l'État de
promouvoir une action culturelle
extérieure on cite souvent les
États-Unis mais c'eston que le deuxième
poste d'exportation est constitué par
les industries culturelles puissance
d'influence la France des talents a des
talents divers
notre pays doit d'abord je pèse mes mots
réapprendre à aimer sa langue
l'architecte de la pensée de la
créativité et s'ouvrir parallèlement à
l'apprentissage d'autres langues
vivantes votre volonté monsieur le
ministre de développer une diplomatie
économique au sein de la Direction
générale de la mondialisation au côté de
la diplomatie culturelle et du français
participe me semble-t-il de cette prise
de conscience n'avez-vous par ailleurs
pas été surpris par une récente étude
d'origine suisse me semble-t-il qui
démontre que les échanges commerciaux
induits par l'appartenance à l'espace
géographique francophone se sont traduit
ces dernières années par un supplément
de PIB par tête de 6 % en moyenne dans
les pays concernés à méditer en tout cas
au regard de ce fort désir de France
observé à l'internationale le moment
n'est-il pas venu monsieur le ministre
de réenchanter à notre tour le rêve de
France sur le territoire nationale je
vous
remercie merci mon cher
collègue dans la suite du débat la
parole est à Madame Catherine main de
sailli groupe udiuc pour 10
minutes monsieur le ministre monsieur le
Président mes chers
collègues la diffusion culturelle au
sens large est aujourd'hui et plus que
jamais un enjeu politique et économique
qu'on ne peut ignorer figurant parmi les
premiers pays pratiquant une diplomatie
culturelle depuis le 18e siècle la
France conserve aujourd'hui une place de
choix dans ce domaine mais doit
s'adapter au nouveaux défis
contemporains
elle attache depuis longtemps une grande
importance aux échanges culturel que ce
soit le cinéma le théâtre les arts les
livres les idées les médias ainsi qu'à
la promotion de la langue française et
au plurilinguisme c'est pourquoi je
voudrais le rappeler fait important la
France est battue pour obtenir de
l'Unesco en 2005 une convention sur la
diversité culturelle et linguistique
elle entretient également un important
réseau d'instituts culturels d'alliances
française et de lycées français à
travers le monde elle contribue au
renforcement de la présence de ces
médias avec TV5 France 24 et RFI au sein
de l'Audiovisuel Extérieur de la France
donc no principaux moyens sont la
mobilité de nos
étudiants le développement de la
recherche et des échanges de
scientifiques et bien entendu la langue
avec l'expansion et l'affirmation de
notre politique en faveur de la
Francophonie la construction
d'équipements phar et le développement
d'OF événementiel apporté international
avec l'exemple aussi des capitales
européennes de la culture ou encore les
expositions universelles qui sont tout
autant d'exemples de moyens d'influence
et de diffusion de la culture néanmoins
il est nécessaire aujourd'hui de
s'interroger sur notre stratégie de
rayonnement culturel et sur les moyens
que l'on souhaite et peut y consacrer ce
débat est donc le bienvenu plus que
jamais nous vivons dans un monde
globalisé et standardisé plus que jamais
la diffusion massive de par le monde de
la culture mainstream nord-américaine
mais d'une certaine manière en péril
notre identité culturelle pas seulement
la nôtre demeurant ainsi plus que jamais
la France et l'Europe ont besoin d'
affirmer de défendre les valeurs qui lui
sont propres et que notre collègue Louis
de ver Louis de Vernois a fort bien
rappelé par ailleurs telleles sont les
conclusions du rapport sur la
gouvernance européenne du numérique que
je viens de terminer au nom de notre
commission des affaires européennes
l'avènement de l'Internet représente un
potentiel énorme de prtion de promotion
de la richesse et de la diversité
culturelle française et européenne mais
elle peut également si nous ny prenons
garde être synonyme d'OM énéisation
culturelle on le sait internet
déstabilise les modalités actuelles du
financement de la culture à la fois par
son apparente gratuité et son absence de
territorialité qui lui permet d'échapper
aux régulations nationales aujourd'hui
si l'expression des contenus émane des
territoires nationaux il revient à
l'Europe d'organiser la stimulation de
la création et la transition numérique
de l'air industrielle en ce domaine
plusieurs instruments que j'évoque dans
mon raort sont mobilisables mais l'Union
doit savoir si elle veut poursuivre ou
non cette politique culturelle ou se
livrer pieds et mains liés à quelques
géants principalement américains qui
ambitionnent d'organiser l'information
du
monde un débat au sein de l'Union est en
cours 12 États dans notre pays ont
appelé en novembre dernier la Commission
à soutenir la culture par une lettre
conjointe au commissaire Vassiliou
Barnier et CROUS les appelant à faire de
la création culturelle en Europe un
enjeu majeur dans ce domaine
principalement nous avons besoin de
renouveler totalement notre stratégie
faute de quoi nous sommes voués au
sous-développement et à nêtre qu'une
colonie du monde numérique ceci étant
dit j'aimerais revenir sur quelques
autres aspects de notre rayonnement
culturel tout d'abord il me semble
opportun de pouvoir évaluer et faire un
bilan des deux premières années de
fonctionnement de l'Institut français
que préside Xavier D'cos il est chargé
dans le cadre de la politique et des
orientations arrêtées par l'État je cite
de porter une ambition renouvelée pour
la diplomatie d'influence et de
contribuer au rayonnement de la France à
l'étranger dans un dialogue renforcé
avec les cultures
étrangères comme l'a rappelé Louis de
Vernois l'Institut a vocation à
s'imposer comme l'opérateur central de
notre action culturelle extérieure en
déclinant selon les zones géographiqu
les priorités stratégiques de notre
politique d'influence pour se faire il
doit articuler et soutenir la
programmation culturelle développée par
notre réseau de 98 établissements à
autonomie financière culturelle et le
réseau associatif des 445 Alliances
françaises conventionnées il lui
appartient en particulier ce qu'ila
commencé de faire de professionnaliser
les leviers de notre dispositif
d'influence culturelle à l'étranger en
mettant l'accent sur la formation de nos
agents culturels et le développement des
outils numériques de diffusion
culturelle et d'enseignement du
français par contre comme le soulignait
notre rapporteur pour avis sur la
mission budgétaire toujours Louis de
Vernois les relations avec les Alliances
françaises mériteraient d'être
clarifiées celles-ci ne doivent pas en
effet être marginalisées en parallèle du
développement de l'Institut français
j'ai encore le le souvenir ému de cette
toute petite Alliance Française
o de résistance au cœur de la forêt
amazonienne à Manaos dans le cadre de
notre mission sur l'année de la France
au Brésil en 2 2009 notre commission de
la culture avait rencontré sa directrice
qui se sentait bien seule et bien
démunie et pourtant quel travail
l'activité des alliances est précieuse
comme notre commission chaque fois
qu'elle se déplace a l'occasion de le
constater aussi le travail de l'Institut
français devrait se concentrer sur
l'animation effective et efficace de
tout le réseau culturel extérieur quelle
est à cet égard monsieur le ministre
votre ambition dans ce domaine quelle
mission nouvelle et innovante
souhaitez-vous confier à l'Institut
français pour qu'il rivalise avec ses
concurrents britanniques ou néerlandais
très bien organisés maintenant
j'aimerais revenir rapidement sur les
crédits de la mission action extérieure
de l'État dans le cadre du projet de loi
de finances pour 2013 on ne peut que
constater et regretter de tel coupe
budgétaire dans un secteur déjà très
contraint naturellement je partage la
nécessité de maîtriser nos dépenses
publiques néanmoins la diplomatie
culturelle et d'influence a déjà subi
d'importantes contraction de ces moyens
on peut regretter que les efforts de
réduction portent principalement sur des
politiques fondamentales les crédits
dédiés à l'animation du réseau qui
comprennent non seulement les frais de
communication d'informatique de mission
et de représentation mais également les
moyens consacré à la formation des
agents diminue de 6,4 %. les créit les
crédits de soutien au réseau culturel
étant en particulier réduit de 5,6 %. de
plus les crédits de la coopération
culturelle et de promotion du français
accuse la baisse la plus importante du
programme de l'ORD de 6,5 million
d'euros soit une diminution de 7,66 %.
or concernant la francophonie un appui
politique fort et déterminé lui est
nécessaire je ne rappellerai pas le rôle
fondamental que joue l'Organisation
internationale de la Francophonie qui
rappelle qui rassemble 63 état dans
cette promotion de la langue française
face notamment à la prééminence de
l'anglais tous les moyens doivent être
mis en œuvre notamment les plus
innovants pour maintenir à travers le
français une diversité linguistique
nécessaire une diversité des idées
quelle est la réflexion du ministère à
ce sujet aussi il est important que la
France renforce sa position sur le
marché international de l'économie du
savoir en exportant l'enseignement
supérieur en français ou à la française
et en cherchant à attirer et à fidéliser
les jeunes générations et notamment les
meilleurs étudiants étranger par des
programmes d'échange et de mobilité là
encore il faudra s'appuyer sur
l'Institut français pour moderniser
l'enseignement du français dans les
systèmes éducatifs locaux et ce à tous
les
niveaux ceci étant dit je voudrais aussi
dire quelques mots des Années croisées
qui ont le bénéfice de l'échange et qui
portent le dialogue des cultures en 2009
dans le rapport d'information que nous
avions rédigé suite au déplacement de
notre commission au Brésil nous
concluons que le bénéfice de tels
investissements devait induire des
développements en matière de coopération
a-t-on aujourd'hui les moyens de ces
évaluations nécessaires on notera que le
rayonnement extérieur de la France ne
passe pas exclusivement d'ailleurs par
l'État et que souvent les territoires
développent des politiques durables
comme nous avons pu le constater il y a
encore de semaines lors du déplacement
de notre commission au Vietnam la
coopération entre la province ué et la
région nordpatcalé entraîner d'autres
coopérations et des réflexes dans les
échanges certains pays de la
francophonie sont très demandeurs du
renforcement de ce type de coopération
pour exemple très concret l'orchestre du
3e cycle de conservatoire de la ville de
Rouin que vous connaissez bien monsieur
le ministre est intervenu avec ses
enseignants à Hanoï à l'occasion de son
millénaire en 2010 en échange de quoi
des étudiants vietnamiens viennent
désormais dans notre ville apprendre la
musique et la langue on le constate les
bénéf fils vont dans les deux sens pour
terminer il me semble indispensable pour
soutenir et mettre en avant toute cette
politique de rayonnement et d'influence
que la France s'appuie sur un
audiovisuel extérieur totalement
imprégné de cette réflexion là encore la
concurrence avec les autres pays doit
nous conduire à renforcer notre pôle
audiovisuel extérieur fort de
l'expérience de TV5 Monde la nouvelle
présidente de laeff Marie Christine
saragos a bien engagé son mandat il faut
la saluer
fin 2011 un rapport de l'Inspection
générale des finances sur la santé
financière des chaînes de laeff
soulignait que si les chaînne avait su
s'imposer malgré un environnement
fortement concurrentiel l'application
d'un principe de précaution budgétaire
et le renforcement des synergies au sein
du groupe devait être mise en œuvre sur
ce sujet pouvez-vous nous éclairer
monsieur le ministre je vous en
remercie merci ma cher collègue la
parole à Madame France ise Laborde pour
le groupe RDSE pour 8
minutes monsieur le président monsieur
le ministre mes chers
collègues tout a changé nous ne sommes
plus les rois du monde c'est ce que
déclarait Bernard couchner alors
ministre des Affaires étrangères en
juillet 201 lorsque fut lancé l'Institut
français la nouvelle agence pour
l'action culturelle extérieure de notre
pays c'est probablement en partie parce
que nous avons cru trop longtemps que
nous étions les rois du monde que notre
diplomatie culturelle accuse un certain
retard et souffre parfois d'un manque de
légitimité l'anthropologue Philippe
Descola professeur au Collège de France
a bien résumé le défi auquel aujourd'hui
est confronté notre diplomatie
d'influence incarner une civilisation
singulière sans pour autant présumer de
la supériorité de sa culture en ce sens
le terme apparemment consensuel de
rayonnement culturel de la France mérite
d'être questionné ne fait-il pas
référence en creux à une certaine
splendeur passée que d'cun aimerait
retrouver sans pour autant remettre en
question notre modèle ne nous
ramène-t-il pas à une époque désormais
lointaine où la culture française
dominait si ce n'est le monde au moins
l'Europe or les choses ont bien changé
notamment depuis la Seconde Guerre
mondiale après laquelle Paris a perdu sa
place de capital des artistes et du
marché de l'art il est sans doute temps
d'en prendre véritablement conscience si
nous voulons construire la diplomatie
culturelle du 21e siècle quand on aborde
l'action culturelle extérieure de la
France il y a deux types de chiffres
ceux qui témoignent de la vitalité et de
l'attractivité de la culture Madine
France dans le monde
50000 manifestations culturelles
organisées chaque année par le réseau
culturel français 101 instituts français
plus de 8000 artistes auteurs ou
professionnels de la culture soutenue
dans plus de 150 pays mais il y a aussi
les chiffres moins glorieux qui
reflèteent le déclin apparemment
irréversible de notre diplomatie
culturelle traditionnelle un/ers de nos
centres et instituts culturels à
l'étranger ont été fermés depuis l'an
2000 le budget de l'action culturelle
extérieure a baissé de plus de 20 %
depuis 2007 cela explique notamment que
dès 2007 un rapport d'information
sénatoriale s'interrogeait sur les
réponses à apportter à une diplomatie
culturelle en crise le chercheur et
journaliste Frédéric Martel adressé un
constat volontairement provocateur
lorsqu'il a déclaré notre réseau
culturel est déprimé ses moyens dilués
sa gouvernance obsolète ses nominations
politisées ou dicté par l'hénarchie
diplomatique bref il ne fonctionne plus
même si je n'adhère pas à de tels propos
ils ont le mérite de soulever un certain
nombre de difficultés réelles que
rencontre notre diplomatie culturelle
depuis plusieurs
années que pouvons-nous donc faire
aujourd'hui pour redynamiser ce ressort
essentiel de toute politique étrangère
complète et efficace les Chinois l'ont
bien compris eux qui investissent
massivement dans leur institut sus
présent à ce jour dans une centaine de
pays alors que les premiers ont ouvert
leurs portes il y a seulement quelques
années si les baisses drastiques de
moyens accordés à notre réseau culturel
à l'étranger ne sont pas acceptables
elles ne nous empêch pas de nous
interroger sur les alternatives
possibles pour développer un véritable
soft power à la
française d'ailleurs particulièrement en
matière de diplomatie d'influence
l'argent n'est peut-être pas uniquement
le nerf de la guerre si je peux
m'exprimer ainsi ce n'est pas parce que
notre Institut français a un budget
supérieur à celui des instituts g
servantes ou des British Concil que
notre diplomatie culturelle est
nécessairement plus efficace d'ailleurs
comment mesurer la réussite et
l'efficacité en la matière c'est une
question délicate si la diplomatie
culturelle est un aspect essentiel de la
diplomatie elle ne doit pas pour autant
être laissée entre les mains des seules
ate aussi brillant soit-il par exemple
BR British Concil ou encore le G
institut sont de véritables bras armé de
la diplomatie culturelle ils sont
cependant autonomes vis-à-vis des
ministères des Affaires étrangères de
leurs pays respectif est-ce ce qui fait
leur force le mot culture est tout aussi
essentiel que celui de diplomatie c'est
peut-être et avant tout non pas aux
diplomates non pas au pouvoirs public en
général mais aux artistes au
professionnel de la culture et aux
industries culturelles elles-mêmes qui
l'incombe de faire vivre la culture
française à travers le monde et de faire
vivre dans le même temps la
francophonie le rôle de la puissance
publique est alors d'encourager
d'accompagner de favoriser les synergies
plutôt que de définir elle-même les
standards culturels qu'ell voudrait voir
rayonner dans tous les pays il est temps
d'arrêter comme cela se passe
malheureusement encore dans certains
services culturels des ambassades de
vouloir imposer de façon unilatérale
notre culture nos artistes nos œuvres
laissons au contraire les acteurs et les
institutions étrangères venir elle-même
naturellement vers eux grâce à une
diplomatie d'influence subtile et
véritablement efficace c'est au nombre
de commissaires d'exposition étranger
qui exposeront des artistes français au
nombre de théâtres qui programmeront des
auteurs ou collaborerons avec des
metteurs en scène français que nous
pourrons mesurer ce fameux rayonnement
culturel
plutôt que de fournir à des
professionnels des expositions
d'artistes français clé en main et des
longs et des et des a ou là je vais pas
y arriver aidons les merci à les
construire c'est d'ailleurs une
condition indispensable pour offrir à
nos artistes une véritable légitimité
internationale un certain nombre
d'initiatives de notre diplomatie
culturel vont d'ailleurs dans ce sens
comme l'échange entre galerie d'art
contemporain française et allemande à
travers le projet Paris-Berlin qui a été
rendu possible grâce au soutien des
services culturels de l'Ambassade de
France à Berlin notre diplomatie
culturelle devra également se saisir
pleinement du potentiel que représente
le numérique encore trop souvent
considéré comme un danger alors qu'il
constitue également une chance
incroyable pour le développement de
notre soft power enfin le rayonnement de
la France passe également par la
capacité de notre réseau diplomatique à
susciter et à encourager le débat
d'idées et les échanges avec les autres
cultures cet axe essentiel de notre
diplomatie culturelle dont nous pouvons
être particulièrement fi mérite d'être
préservé et
renforcé la diplomatie culturelle peut
également se manifester en passant par
d'autres canaux notamment ceux d'une
diplomatie plus classique ou hard power
dans le domaine commercial par exemple
la récente de l'engagement des
négociations d'un accord de libre
échange historique entre l'Union
européenne et les États-Unis ont relancé
le débat sur l'exception culturelle
défendu par certains diplomates français
dans les coulisses du GATT puis de l'OMC
dans les années 90 et cette notion a
finalement abouti à la Convention de
l'UNESCO sur la diversité culturelle de
2005 constant sur ce point le président
de la République a Maré a déclaré le 15
mars dernier que l'exception culturelle
ne devrait donc plus faire partie des
points de négociation dans l'accord de
libre échange UE États-Unis pour
conclure je souhaite insister sur la
nécessité de donner une dimension
européenne à la diplomatie culturelle
aujourd'hui c'est en construisant avec
nos voisins l'identité d'une culture
européenne dont la force réside dans la
diversité et qui ne signifie en rien
l'effacement des cultures nation ou
régional que nous pourrons construire un
software véritablement puissant face aux
États-Unis qui reste encore pour
l'instant les mettre en la matière mais
aussi face aux puissantes émergentes
dans ce domaine comme la Chine ou les
pays du Golf je vous remercie merci ma
cher collègue la parole à madame la
Présidente Blandin pour le groupe
écologiste pour 7
minutes monsieur président
monsieur le président monsieur le
ministre mes chers collègues si la
compétition est une réalité dans le
monde d'aujourd'hui la culture mérite
mieux que l'exacerbation des rivalités
même avec des moyens modeste et
particulièrement avec des moyens
modestes c'est la qualité des liens
tissés qui Orte la France riche par son
histoire de ressources et de compétences
de nombreuses institutions en charge de
l'action extérieure doit veiller à ne
pas faire montre de supériorité par
rapport aux autres pays qui ont bien
compris l'importance de la diplomatie
culturelle et de la sobriété de ton dans
le monde d'aujourd'hui une grande
attention doit être portée à ce que nos
opérateurs ou représentants ne se
fassent pas de concurrence
déconcertante sur le terrain la forme de
la précédente mandature a donné la main
au qu d'orsé qui a ses propres
stratégies et qui s'inscrit aussi dans
des conflits mondiaux auxquels la France
a décidé de prendre part mais la culture
est un dialogue permanent entre les
peuples qui ne s'arrête ni aux
frontières ni aux conflits dans lesquels
elle doit rester le fil ténu qui permet
encore de s'entendre de faire raisonner
les atouts de la diversité culturelle le
ement ne se décrète pas il s'apprécie à
postériori dans l'estime que nous
gagnons à chaque fois que nous ouvrons
des espace de formation que nous faisons
se rencontrer des artistes circuler des
œuvres dans les deux sens bien sûr
chaque fois que des équipes mixtes de
recherche travaillent pour répondre à de
vrais besoins et partagent la signature
des
publications l'impératif de maîtrise des
finances publiques ne doit pas nous
faire perdre de vue que l'action
culturelle extérieure de la France est à
appréhander comme un investissement
d'avenir nous sommes attendus sur la
formation des formateurs en enseignement
artistique sur la francophonie et les
échanges de professeurs et d'étudiants
sur les meilleures méthodes d'aide au
cinéma à l'édition à la protection des
droits des artistes à la gestion du
patrimoine nous avons à apprend prendre
et à nous émerveiller des cultures à
découvrir et nous navrons nos
amis et nous na'avrons nos amis quand au
nom de la prévention de l'immigration
clandestine nous bloquons aux frontières
le violoniste du sextuor àorde les
percussionnistes africains du festival
de bidon un jeune chercheur en
informatique qui sera accueilli les bras
ouverts chez Apple et l'incompréhension
est totale quand notre consulat de
Yaoundé ne délivre pas de visa à la
déléguée africaine de l'école freinée
l'empêchant de venir au Congrès mondial
malgré son billet de retour Bayer malgré
son hébergement assuré malgré son
invitation montrée et malgré les
interventions de plusieurs
parlementaires c'était avant
2012 alors les écologistes attendent le
changement et des preuves
nous sommes convaincus que l'attention
portée à la réciprocité porte davantage
d'espoir de retomber des changes plus
marchant et durable qu'une volonté
offensive de rayonnement porté par la
seule envie de nouveau marché
malheureusement les missions culturelles
du ministère des Affaires étrangères ont
subi une baisse significative de leur
crédit repenser notre politique de
coopération culturelle en sortant des
vieux schéma hérité de la période
post-coloniale demande que la culture ne
soit pas la cerise sur le gâteau de
notre politique de développement dans un
monde en tension la coopération
culturelle est un moyen de prévention
des conflits sans culture pas de paix et
sans paix pas de développement possible
aussi je pense que l'Agence française de
développement gagnerait à en soutenir
les projets de a tour d'un déplacement
au Vietnam avec une délégation de la
Commission de la culture j'ai noté que
le financement de la saison croisée
était assuré pour plus d'un tiers par
les entreprises et que c'était l'attaché
d'ambassade en charge des questions
économiques qui de fait gérait les
dossiers davantage que le conseiller
culturel le MES Sénat ne saurait
dissimuler un désengagement financier de
l'État qui ne serait pas un bon signal
envoyé à nos partenaires savez-vous que
l'École Française d'Extrême Orient ne
compte aujourd'hui plus qu'un seul
chercheur en poste à hanoil contre trois
auparavant toujours en matière de
recherche alors que l'Europe nous emmène
vers une mutualisation de nos outils de
coopération notre agence nationale de
recherche ne finance pas les projets
montés en collaboration avec des équipes
étrangère n'est-ce pas contradictoire
pour vous éviter un tableau trenoir je
tiens néanmoins saluer l'excellent
modèle que représente le laboratoire de
recherche consacré à la génomique du riz
qui permet un partenariat exemplaire de
chercheurs français et vietnamiens avec
de jeunes étudiants sur un sujet
essentiel pour l'avenir et la sécurité
alimentaire du Vietnam et ceci sans OGM
ni brevet
confiscatoire je suis en revanche
toujours déçu du peu d'importance donnée
par l'État l'action de nos collectivités
territoriales parfois réduite au simple
statut de cofinanceur alors qu'elles
savent souvent tisser des liens plus
étroits dans la durée enfin pour
conclure je souhaite que la France fasse
vivre partout la Convention de
l'UNESCO relative à la diversité
culturelle ce texte de référence doit
s'appliquer dans toutes ses dimensions
et inspiré de multiples chantiers auquel
nous pourrons prendre pas par des
coproductions par une diffusion de
qualité en lien avec nos partenaires et
dans le respect de leurs attentes je
vous remercie
merci la parole à Monsieur rené Beaumont
pour le groupe umep pour 14
minutes
bien monsieur le
président monsieur le ministre mes chers
collègues nous savons tous que la
dimension culturelle et linguistique
constitue un atout incontournable pour
le développement et l'influence de notre
pays et la promotion de nos
intérêts héritière d'un patrimoine
prestigieux
d'une culture vivante et d'une certaine
singularité dans l'expression de ses
positions la France bénéficie encore
d'une attractivité forte cependant la
place de la France se banalise sur sur
la scène mondiale bien sûr elle reste
encore dans le domaine de la culture et
des idées une puissance qui compte mais
jusqu'à
quand dans le contexte de la
mondialisation le rayonnement culturel
de la France est soumis des tensions
contradictoires toutefois le nombre de
personnes pouvant avoir accès à la
culture française n'a jamais été aussi
important ce grâce bien sûr aux
nouvelles technologie de l'information
qui offre des capacités de diffusion
considérables nos opérateurs culturels
nationaux et privés dans le domaine des
arts mais aussi des sciences les
utilisent largement les universités les
centres de recherche et les opérateurs
en charge de l'action culturelle
extérieure y ont recours également leurs
contenus sont diffusés en langue
française mais aussi de plus en plus
font-ils l'objet d'une traduction pour
accroître leur diffusion ainsi le nombre
de personnes susceptibles dans le monde
d'accéder à ces contenus est infini et
limité simplement par l'accès au
technologie et les obstacles posés par
certains États qui souhaitent contrôler
l'accès au site
internet les nouvelles technologie nous
offre donc un potentiel extraordinaire
pour décupler nos efforts et nous devons
nous y atteler car la concurrence
étrangère y est très sévère
également non seulement nos concurrents
traditionnels américains britannique
allemands accentuent leurs efforts mais
on voit bien qu'avec le développement
des nouvelles technologies d'autres
puissances émergentes sont beaucoup plus
offensives et ment une action culturelle
au-delà de de leurs frontières comme la
Chine les pays du golf ou encore la
Turquie dans Lee dans le monde
arabomusulman la capacité de rayonnement
culturel d'un État à l'étranger va donc
dépendre très largement de sa capacité à
créer des conditions d'assurer la
promotion de sa culture et de sa langue
qui qui en est le premier vecteur à
l'étranger bien sûr or cette promotion
suppose des investissements que mal que
malgré le désir de France que l'on
observe lorsqu'on se déplace à à
l'étranger nous sommes parfois en mal de
financer
aujourd'hui or cette
promotion le budget voté pardon pour
2013 dans le domaine de la diplomatie
culturelle et d'influence et
caractéristiqu de ces limites puisqu'il
se traduit par une stabilité apparente
mais qui masque en effet une réduction
continue des
moyens en effet les crédits du programme
185 sont en diminution de 0,5 % parce
que leur compéten leur composant pardon
majeur en termees budgétaires l'Agence
pour l'Enseignement de français à
l'étranger n'est pas affectée par les
règles de cadrage imposé aux autres
secteurs nombre de composantes se voit
appliquer des réductions de crédit
pouvant aller jusqu'à 7
%. pensons à l'Institut
français notre collègue du Vernois a
largement décrit tout à l'heure dont la
loi du 27 juillet 2010 a fait
l'opérateur de l'action culturelle
extérieure à la France se trouve aussi
avec une diminution de - 7
% pensons au crédit sur pour opération
du réseau culturel dans ces deux
composantes et les Alliances françaises
en particulier avec Mo- 7 % est-ce
donneré les meilleurs atouts à la
rénovation de nos outils
entreprise sous le gouvernement de
François Fillon il est vrai mais sur la
base d'un rapport conjoint des
commissions de la culture et des
Affaires étrangères du Sénat adopté à
l'unanimité il faut le
rappeler sans doute des économies
peuvent-elles être réalisées mais je c
je crains qu'à force de récurrence
on en soit davantage à réduire à réduire
la voilure plutôt qu'à rechercher des
gains de
productivité la dernière dernière
invention est l'appelle
l'autofinancement qui il est vrai est
devenu un indicateur de gestion et de
performance qui figure en bonne place
dans les outils d'évaluation du projet
annuel de performance et des contrats
d'objectifs et de moyens mais il a aussi
ses limites d'abord selon la nature des
activités la régularité de la ressource
peut-elle être plus ou moins
certaine si en
2011 les écoles d'enseignement du
français ont réuni un montant de
cofinancement de
174,6 million d'euros pour l'essentiel
grâce au cours de langue bien sûr le
montant attendu pour 2012 ne devrait
être que de 150 millions seulement
ensuite des disparités existent dans les
domaines d'activité mais aussi selon les
pays selon les ressources selon les
degrés d'implication de entreprises
françaises selon la conjoncture
économique bien sûr aussi il ne faudrait
pas que la quête d'autofinancement
introduise des facteur d'exclusion et se
traduisent par un désengagement dans les
pays économiques les plus
vulnérables j'ajoute enfin que les
entreprises en période de crise
réduisent singulièrement les montants
qu'elles peuvent consacrer à des actions
de mesenna et se tourne en priorité vers
la préservation de leurs Marg et surtout
de leurs
emplois la la conciliation du
développement de nos actions et des
restructurations en cours dans un tel
contexte budgétaire est une équation
impossible c'est bel et bien une
réduction à une réduction des activités
de notre opérateur et des réseaux à
laquelle nous allons
assister je me réjouis en revanche des
efforts conduits en matière
d'attractivité et de mobilité des jeunes
c'est un enjeu important y compris dans
le financement de notre système
d'enseignement
supérieur la population étudiante
étrangère atteint près de 290000
étudiants soit une augmentation de 65 %
en 10 ans et représente aujourd'hui 12,3
% des étudiants inscrits il existe une
demande forte mais aussi une véritable
concurrence
internationale puisque selon les données
de l'UNESCO la mobilité internationale
étudiante table sur un doublement de la
mobilité étudiante à l'étranger dans les
10 prochaines
années soit sans doute de l'ordre de 7
millions d'étudiants en 2025
aujourd'hui la France reste bien placée
mais la part relative des intervenants
traditionnels commence à se réduire avec
l'arrivée de nouveaux entrants notamment
en Asie il est important que nous
puissions maintenir nos capacités car
c'est un élément d'influence que de
pouvoir former les élites des autres
pays et pas seulement dans le domaine
des humanités mais aussi dans les
domaines des sciences et des
technologies bien
sûr notre notre attractiv doit d'abord
se fonder sur l'excellence de nos cursus
de formation et sur la capacité à à
proposer des formations de standards
international et adaptable aux besoins
des
publics la la politique de bourse est
évidemment est évidemment un pilier
important mais à condition d'être
vraiment sélective enfin il appartient à
l'État d'être un
facilitateur en diffusant l'information
en favorisant les partenariats et en
apportant des services
à cet égard je me réjouis de la
rationalisation de nos outils et du
développement par Campus France d'une
capacité à proposer au gouvernement
étranger notamment des pays émergents un
système performant de gestion des
bourses de leurs étudiants en France et
ce au-delà de leur suivi en apportant en
outre des ressources nécessaires à son
financement sans solliciter le budget de
l'État car nombre de gouvernements
étrangers ont mis en place des
financements des études à l'étranger de
leurs ressortissant qu'il considère
comme un investissement
d'avenir le partenariat conclut avec le
Brésil récemment dans le cadre de son
programme Scien sans Sans Frontières est
exemplaire le développement de cette
politique suppose néanmoins quelques
moyens budgétaire et je cras je crains à
observer l'utilisation des crédits de la
diplomatie culturelle et d'influence
comme une traditionnelle variable nous
nous nousous nous nous puissions dans
les années à venir bien sûr poursuivre
nos
efforts peut-être me me démantirez-vous
monsieur le ministre je le souhaite
d'ailleurs j'ajoute que ns que nous
sommes toujours en attente du projet des
contrats d'objectifs et de moyens de
Campus France dans ce contexte
économique et budgétaire difficile ce
qui me nare c'est l'impression que la
limitation des crédits résulte d'une
application quasi uniforme qui ne qui ne
permettent même pas d'afficher les
moindres priorités à notre action on a
un peu l'impression monsieur le ministre
d'un navire sur son air dont on alimente
de moins en moins le moteur mais auquel
on ne donne plus de véritables
orientation et quand on dit des
orientations cela veut dire des
priorités thématiques est-ce l'action
culturelle est-ce l'attractivité et la
mobilité des jeunes est-ce la
coopération scientifique votre ministère
vient d'annoncer une stratégie portant
sur la diplomatie scientifique est-ce le
développement du français à l'étranger
faut-il continuer à conventionner et à
créer des établissements qu'un
établissement étranger le dès qu'un
établissement étranger le souhaite
pardon monsieur le ministre vous avez
annoncé à l'automne dernier en
commission une réflexion sur ce sujet où
en est-on quelles sont les premières
orientations est-ce la diffusion de la
langue française pouvez nous dire
pouvez-vous nous dire où nous en sommes
de la rédaction du contrat d'objectif et
des moyens de
la cela implique nécessairement des
priorité géographique également quels
sont les pays cibles dans quelle zone
voulons-nous voulons-nous informer pr
affirmer pardon pr prioritairement notre
présence dans quel moyen de quel moyen
affectez-vous à ces
priorités mais cela signifie qu'en
contrepartie parce que choisir c'est
aussi renoncer nous devons indiquer là
où nous limiterons désormais notre
présence et nos
efforts nous devons donc fixer le
dispositif minimum que nous souhaitons
conserver ce afin de restructurer notre
réseau pour organiser un dispositif
minimum ainsi monsieur le ministre je
reconnais qu'au cours de mon propos je
vous ai soumis à la question tout au
moins beaucoup de questions mais la
représentation nationale monsieur le
ministre doit connaître toutes ses
orientations pour pouvoir en apprécier
la portée ça me paraît aussi essentiel
ainsi votre présence ce soir dans cet
hémicycle vous per mettra de donner un
peu plus de relief aux pistes que vous
avez déjà esquissé mais dont nous avons
encore du mal à trouver à trouver une
véritable
concrétisation je vous
remercie merci mon cher collègue la
parole à Monsieur le président
Jean-Louis carrer pour 7
minutes
monsieur le Président mon cher
Didier monsieur le
président monsieur le ministre mes chers
collègues le rayonnement culturel d'un
pays ne se décrête pas il est un état au
sens physique du terme qui résulte de la
combinaison de plusieurs
facteurs le rayonnement culturel est
d'abord fonction de l'intensité du
patrimoine culturel ça a été rappelé de
ce point de vue la France reste une
référence une matrice qui continue de
produire et c'est bien là le plus
important une continuité à ne pas perdre
cependant en ce domaine l'action de
l'État consiste à maintenir un
environnement favorable à la création
culturelle à son renouvellement à son
investissement sur de nouveaux supports
et de nouveaux modes d'expression elle
repose sur l'éducation et
l'investissement public dans la
politique du gouvernement nous mesurons
monsieur le ministre et soutenons
l'effort consenti dans le domaine de
l'éducation nous sommes plus inquiets
sur l'investissement dans le domaine de
la création s'agissant du rayonnement
culturel à
l'étranger il me semble que les filières
qui permettent de développer
l'excellence française ne doivent pas
être négligé car elle tire ses secteurs
vers le haut et permettent l'exportation
de modèles de référ
mais le rayonnement culturel est aussi
la capacité pour une culture de
prétendre à
l'universel cela suppose une capacité à
dialoguer avec l'extérieur et à intégrer
pour se renouveler sans perdre de son
être là où la liberté d'expression
culturelle est restreinte là où les
idées ne peuvent pas être confronté le
rayonnement culturel
stiole il est fondamental que notre pays
continue à défendre la liberté de
l'expression culturelle sous toutes ses
formes milite pour la liberté de
diffusion des œuvres et accueil des
artistes
étrangers il doit aussi préserver
l'économie qui soutend la création
artistique et donc faire en sorte que
cette liberté ne se trouve absorbée par
des lois du marché qui
l'affaiblissent la mondialisation de la
diffusion des productions culturelles
est relativement paradoxale d'une part
les nouvelles technologies permettent
une diffusion quasi universelle à
moindre coout et de s'adresser
directement aux individus il y en a qui
l'ont bien
compris même en d'autres expériences que
la diffusion culturelle de ce point de
vue le rayonnement culturel de la France
à l'étranger est sans doute plus
important qu'il n'a jamais été mais
d'autre part la concurrence plus vite
entre producteurs et le dialogue entre
les cultures peuvent aussi déboucher sur
un risque d'uniformisation des goûts et
une standardisation des produits au
mépris de la créativité tout est donc
pour l'État dans sa législation
intérieure mais aussi sur la scène
internationale qui s'empare
progressivement de la régulation des
industries culturelles d'affirmer en
modèle sans pour autant monsieur le
ministre s'isoler afin de continuer à
diffuser productions originales
enfin le rayonnement à l'étranger est
fonction de notre capacité à promouvoir
notre culture je serais tenté de dire a
suscité un désir de
France l'intervention de l'État reste
indispensable car notre secteur culturel
est fragile surtout lorsque la
concurrence s'accroit avec des
puissances de plus en plus nombreuses
qui déploient une diplomatie culturelle
et il consacre des moyens très
importants y compris dans nos zones
traditionnelles d'influence c'est dans
ce cadre qu'a été entreprise une
modernisation de nos outils par la mise
en place d'opérateurs cette
modernisation doit se poursuivre dans le
sens d'une plus grande autonomie parce
qu'elle professionnalise la gestion et
pérénise des modes d'action le pilotage
par le biais de contrat d'objectif me
paraît une solution
intéressante si l'État se contente de
fixer des objectifs réalistes apporte
les moyens en conséquence et surtout de
façon régulière et enfin se dote et ceci
est très important vous le savez d'une
véritable capacité d'évaluation des
opérateurs voilà Monsieur le Ministre
quelques observations général qui me
semble-t-il devrait orienter pourrait
orienter notre réflexion les rapporteurs
pour avis de la commission des affaires
étrangères messieur valimi et Besson
s'exprimeront sur leur domaines
respectifs le rayonnement culturel est
sans doute monsieur le ministre l'un des
meilleurs atouts d'influence dont nous
disposons vous trouverez dans cette
assemblée des soutiens actifs car
conscient des enjeux de long terme que
représente l'action culturelle
extérieure pour maintenir et dével
l'influence de la
France
Merci la parole à Monsieur Michel learnc
pour le groupe CRC pour 8
minutes monsieur le Président Monsieur
le ministrees chers collègues le
rayonnement culturel international est
une composante à part entière de la
politique étrangère française dans un
monde globalisé où intérêt économique
culturel et diplomatique paraissent plus
que jamais lié il est fondamental il est
la base de notre pouvoir doux j'ai
entendu soft power comme l'a théorisé
Joseph ni et il est constitutif de la
diplomatie d'influence le rayonnement
culturel permet d'influer indirectement
un certain nombre d'acteurs
internationaux par des moyens non
coercitifs contrairement au hard power
au pouvoir dur c'est la capacité à
séduire et convaincre d'autres États
sans utiliser la force ainsi la langue
les idées la création artistique concour
au développement du positionnement et de
l'influence générale et durable de notre
pays à l'étranger elle permet de
promouvoir intérêt politique et
économique par le soutien des échanges
artistiques et le développement de
l'apprentissage de notre langue la
France apparaît de ce point de vue assez
bien positionné sur la scène mondiale
mais ce modèle français ne doit pas
cacher un certain nombre de problèmes et
de faiblesses qui pourrai continuer à
dégrader notre situation dans l'avenir
la France a un réseau encore puissant en
France la diplomatie culturelle s'appuie
sur la coopération et les actions
culturelles des ambassades elle
constitue de ce point de vue le premier
réseau mondial avec ses 154 services de
coopération et d'action culturelle la
France possède également le premier
réseau scolaire à l'étranger nous sommes
présents dans plus de 130 pays avec 485
établissements qui accueillent
aujourd'hui environ 310000 élèves dont
115000 français ceci est positif Campus
France créé en 2010 avec 175 espaces
dans 110 pays regroupe sous un statut
unique d'épque l'ensemble des moyens
humains et financiers de l'enseignement
supérieur français à l'étranger
concourrant à un même objectif de
valorisation de l'image et de
l'influence de notre pays à cette action
s'ajoutent les 145 instituts et centres
culturels dans 92 pays et les 104
Alliances françaises dans 134 pays qui
si elles ne dépendent pas directement du
ministère des Affaires étrangères
bénéficie pour 300 d'entre elles d'une
aide financière de votre ministère tous
contribuent quel que soit leur statut au
rayonnement de la culture française
notamment par l'offre de cours de
français à l'étranger chapauté depuis
2010 par l'Institut français censé
coordonner l'action culturelle
internationale le réseau culturel
français est donc puissant mais il est
déclinant ce déclin et ce déclin est
conforté par un désengagement financier
et humain si la France est encore
considéré comme un modèle en terme de
rayonnement culturel à l'étranger
puisque nos partenaires d'Amérique
latine d'Asie du nord-est sollicitent
encore notre expertise le constat du
recul d'influence français sur le
terrain culturel le pardon le constat du
recul de l'influence française sur le
terrain culturel du déclin de la
Francophonie et l'étonnement des pays
francophones à avoir la France en
retrait dans le combat pour la promotion
de sa langue et de sa culture est une
réalité la culture française est moins
présente aujourd'hui sur la scène
mondiale qu'il y a quelques décennies la
langue et la culture française sont en
recul l'anglais est la langue
internationale et la langue officielle
dans 94 pays sans compter tous les pays
où il est couramment parlé tandis que le
français est une langue officielle dans
54 pays l'influence culturelle de la
France diminue en conséquence alors même
qu'elle est au fondement de son action
et de sa conception de la diplomatie et
pour cause malgré son importance
stratégique la diplomaie culturelle a
été soumise durement à la RGPP avec
suppression d'emploi et diminution
drastique de ces moyens force de
constater et nous regretons que le
nouveau gouvernement n'a pas inversé
suffisamment dans les orientations
budgétaires le budget 2013 est inscrit
est ainsi inscrit dans l'effort de
réduction des dépenses publiques avec
184 postes supprimé en 2013 quant à la
baisse des crédits budgétaires de
l'ordre de - 7 % en 2013 - 4 % en 2014
et de - 4 % également en 2015 ce qui
fera au total de 2012 à 2000 à l'horizon
2015 environ 15 % de baisse quant au
programme 185 spécifiquement consacré à
la diplomatie culturelle et d'influence
pour l'année 2013 et hors dépenses de
personnel il s'élève à 665 millions
d'euros à structure courante mais
représente une légère diminution de 0,54
% par rapport à 2012 certains
instruments de la diplomatie d'influence
ont certes été préservés conformément
aux priorités et orientations
gouvernementales mais cela ne suffira
s'ans doute pas enrayer le déclin le
secteur de l'enseignement est ainsi
préservé les bourses de de mobilité des
étudiants étranger en France constitue
le cœur du dispositif d'influence et
d'attractivité de la France et du
français la dotation qui est consacrée à
ce dispositif reste stable les crédits
pour les échanges d'expertise et
scientifiqu sont également maintenu à
leur niveau de 2012 la diplomatie
culturelle est ainsi recentrée sur une
vision plus utilitaire dans la
perspective très claire d'éventuel
débouché économique cette baisse de
moyens intervient à un moment où les
grands pays émergents conscients du
pouvoir de ce rayonnement culturel
commencec à investir pour imiter notre
modèle lancé par Pékin en 2004 qui a
ouvert 6 établissements cette année-là
dans le premier dont le premier implanté
en France le réseau confutius a connu
depuis lors une croissance exponentielle
qui ne s'est pas ralenti 118 centres
créés dès 2006 249 en 2008 et 358 en
2010 l'objectif étant de 500 institut
dans le monde la France loin de
s'implanter à des points stratégiques
des pays en plein développement consacre
la majorité de ses effectifs et
ressources à l'Europe ou à ses anciennes
colonies contrairement aux allemands et
britanniques qui n'hésitent pas à
déléguer en Europe pour mieux s'imposer
dans les pays émergents c'est dans ce
contexte global que ces dernières années
l'approche de la France pouvait sembler
plus timorer avec des moyens et
instruments dédiés à ce volet de sa
politique extérieure plus modeste et
moins efficace ainsi le Maroc reste le
premier budget du réseau français pour
des raisons historiques et en fonction
de l'héritage colonial mais les
investissements dans les pays émergents
notamment les briques Brésil Russie Inde
et Chine ne sont pas revalorisés si le
rayonnement culturel a pour finalité
d'améliorer l'attractivité de la France
de promouvoir ses savoir-faires sa
culture et ses créations la France doit
se positionner davantage sur les pays
d'avenir le risque est que la baisse de
l'influence française continue alors
alors qu'elle a été porteuse d'initiativ
internationales fortes telles que
l'exception culturelle et la lutte
contre l'impérialisme culturel dans un
contexte de mondialisation l'enjeu va
même au-delà de la stratégie nationale
politique et économique il en va de la
survie de spécificités culturelles dans
un monde globalisé uniformisé notre
culture est porteuse de paix et de
solidarité la France doit poursuivre ses
efforts il en va de notre avenir et de
notre espoir commun je vous
remercie merci mon cher collègue la
parole à Monsieur Christophe André
Frassa pour le groupe umep pour 10
minutes
monsieur le ministre monsieur le
Président pardon monsieur le ministre
les chers collègues en tant que sénateur
représentant les Français établis hors
de France je serai naturellement voir
originellement tenté d'évoquer devant
vous des sujets tels que la prise en
charge des frais de scolarité ou
l'Agence pour l'enseignement français à
l'étranger car ce sont des outils qui
répondent aux besoins de nos expatriés
mais qui participent également à notre
rayonnement culturel j'ai entendu les
différents et brillants orateurs avant
moi alors je vais essayer d'éviter les
redites chacun de nous sait que la
France bénéficie de l'un des réseaux
diplomatiques les plus denses et les
plus anciens mais je me laisse à penser
que ça c'était avant notre réseau est le
fruit du travail de personnalité issu de
la société civile qui au fil des siècles
et d'expéditions non'ont cessé de
promouvoir les valeurs et les
connaissances françaises dans le monde
entier de créer un besoin et de rép
répondre à une immense attente de France
ce réseau est un héritage inestimable
par son histoire son ancienneté sa
diversité mais comme tous les héritage
il importe de le faire fructifier sinon
il serait dilapidé et risquerait de
disparaître et c'est malheureusement ce
qu'il se passe car le rayonnement
culturel et l'influence française
reculent quoi qu'on en dise et autant
qu'on puisse le regretter c'est pour
cela que notre politique doit s'adapter
aux nouveaux comportements et aux
nouvelles
attentes c'est le résultat de la
confluence de plusieurs phénomènes à
commencé par la concurrence féroce des
pays qui n'ont plus rien d'émergent et
par la mise en place de politiques très
offensive de la part d'autres pays comme
les États-Unis ou la Chine en 2013 nous
sommes bien loin des seules stratégies
d'influence fondé sur le seul
rayonnement culturel l'héritage des
philosophes des Lumières ou d'un style
d'architecture mes chers collègues vous
pardonnerez mon pragmatisme face au
nouveaux défis de la mondialisation nous
ne sommes plus en mesure budgétairement
et structurellement de répondre à la
demande de France à l'étranger et cela
parce que nous la suscitons de moins en
moins aujourd'hui nous faisons face à la
concurrence des instituts culturels
emblématiques très facilement
reconnaissabl et identifiaable que ce
soit le British Council les Instituts
Confucius ou G ces établissements
représentent bien plus qu'un patrimoine
culturel ils sont ni plus ni moins une
marque nationale d'ailleurs
permettez-moi d'observer que ces
instituts ont un point commun les pays
qu'il incarne à l'étranger sont des pays
dont les gouvernements savent faire face
à la crise c'est cela le véritable Smart
power qu' a souhaité mettre en place
Hillary Clinton lors du premier mandat
de Barack Obama j'en profite au passage
pour rappeler que nous avons voté ici il
y a 2 ans une loi sur l'action
extérieure de l'État permettant de
rendre plus lisible et efficace notre
action extérieure et cela s'est traduit
par la création de l'Institut français
ce dont je me félicite toutefois la
création des pics et leur meilleure
coordination ne suffit pas à palier ce
recul d'influence de la France mais en
fin de compte nous possédions un
établissement à vocation culturelle
enfin facilement
identifiable il impor il importe
aujourd'hui d' d'adopter pardon une
stratégie globale de diplomatie
culturelle et d'influence non plus sous
le seul prisme de l'action extérieure de
l'État qu'en est-il aujourd'hui la
diplomatie culturelle et d'influence ou
ce qu'il convient d'appeler le soft
power se mesure à l'ône du dynamisme de
notre pays et de sa bonne santé
économique et financière or peu d'entre
nous vous me
contrediront notre pays est plongé dans
un marasme économique duquel nous ne
sommes pas prêts de sortir or notre pays
ne parvient pas à donner confiance ni
aux Français en France ni aux
investisseurs internationaux selon une
étude du cabinet price waterhous Coopers
rendu en janvier dernier le nombre des
jeunes Français expatriés devrait
augmenter de 50 % dans les années à
venir vous voyez mes chers collègues les
futurs exilés ne sont pas des
milliardaires fuyant dissimuler des
comptes bancaires mais simplement des
jeunes en quête d'un avenir meilleur et
d'abord et avant tout en quête d'un
emploi qu'il ne trouve plus en France
d'ailleurs en terme d'attractivité des
pays tels que l'Australie la Corée du
Sud le Canada Singapour ou la Chine
accueille bon nombre de nos jeunes à
titre d'exemple la moyenne d'âge des
quelques 20000 Français de shanghï est
de 29 ans tout ceci à terme peut devenir
inquiétant car il ne faudrait pas que
nous assistions à de trop nombreux
départs de futurs actifs qualifiés si
j'étais provocateur ce que je ne suis
pas je vous diraiis que le rayonnement
culturel français devrait d'abord
s'exercer auprès des Français et à
l'intérieur de nos frontières pour
revenir plus plus précisément sur le
rayonnement culturel de la France à
l'étranger je souhaite rendre hommage à
nos personnels diplomatiques qui font
avec ceux qu'ils ont c'est-à-dire peu et
qui UVR pour que la France maintienne
son rang sur la scène internationale et
ce à un moment où leur sécurité peut
être compromise de même je pense à nos
expatriés qui a à côté de nos personnels
diplomatiqu et de coopération sont les
ambassadeurs civils de notre pays parce
qu'il continuent d'entreprendre et
assure la promotion de ce qu'il reste
d'énergie parce que cela est
financièrement et administrativement
trop lourd en France ils sont les
premiers acteurs de la Francophonie
alors quand on lit deci de là que ce
sont des exilés fiscaux qu'il
manqueraiit de patriotisme on ne peut
que s'insurger parce que c'est
lamentable de dire cela et plus
qu'irrespectueux envers ceux qui sont
des pionniers de cette envie de France
que nous sou onant suscité monsieur le
monsieur le ministre vous me pardonnerez
ces propos un peu vifs parce que vous
pensez la même chose que moi à ce sujet
et parce que nous voulons tous ici la
même chose plus de France et encore
mieux de France à l'étranger je vous
remercie merci mon cher
collègue la parole à Monsieur Jean
Bessan pour le groupe socialiste pour 7
minutes
monsieur le
Président Monsieur le président monsieur
le ministre mes chers collègues le
président Jean-Louis carer vous a un
instant appelé à actualiser notre
démarche stratégique en matière de
diplomatie d'influence nous avions
engagé au sein de l'assemblée au sein de
cette Assemblée il y a 5 ans un travail
de réflexion de grande ampleur conjoint
aux commissions des affaires étrangères
et de la culture ce travail a débouché
sur un rapport adopté chose RAR à
l'unanimité je lisais hier les constats
opérés et les propositions faites à
l'époque en matière d'action culturelle
et nous pourrions reprendre aujourd'hui
ce constat sans doute la loi du ça a été
dit bien entendu la loi du 27 juillet
2010 a-t-elle mis en place des
opérateurs euh comme l'Institut français
Campus France et France expertise
internationale dont la vocation est de
professionnaliser et rationaliser la
diplomatie culturelle et d'influence
c'est notre
souhait mais nous sommes restés au
milieu du
gay et les mêmes faiblesses continuent
de peser sur le développement de notre
action culturelle extérieure alors que
nous sommes confrontés à une concurrence
de plus en plus grande notamment de la
part des pays émergants comme la Chine
ou les pays de golf et singulièrement le
Qatar il faut compter bien entendu sur
les opérateurs privés ONG fondation
entreprise je remarque d'ailleurs qu'à
l'exception de quelques opérateurs
public dans le
domaine muséographique ou quelques
grandes écoles ou unersité dans le
secteur éducatif nos opérateurs privés
sont peu engagés dans ce domaine c'est
un constat il a sans
doute pas assez de marchés suffisamment
porteurs pour soutenir leurs actions je
ne veux pas avoir une vision trop
décliniste car les moyens modernes de
communication permettent aujourd'hui une
diffusion importante de notre culture et
de nos idées en s'afranchissant des
barrières étatiques encore que le
perfectionnement des outils de contrôle
de l'Internet à certains états très
puissants engage donc des obstructions
dans le domaine de l'Internet toutefois
la baisse tendantielle de nos moyens
depuis de nombreuses années quel que
soit les gouvernements est une source
d'inquiétude très vive le rayonnement
culturel est une affaire de long terme
sans doute mais à force de réduire notre
investissement nous nous perdons
effectivement notre influence et
retrouver un crédit trop souvent trop
coûteux parfois impossible nous avons
mis en place les opérateurs mais leurs
moyens sont en diminution pour 2013 la
dotation budgétaire de l'Institut
français est en baisse de 7 % celle des
réseaux de 4 % il en va de même pour le
soutien aux alliances françaises le
principal objectif est donc de réaliser
des économies ou de rechercher des
ressources propres je veux bien admettre
que la recherche des solutions moins
coûteuses et plus efficaces soit un
exercice vertueux je salue à cet égard
la remise en ordre de la mobilité des
étudiants étrangers à travers Campus
France la modernisation de la diffusion
culturelle par l'utilisation des
nouvelles technologies par l'Institut
français les réflexions engagé pour
orienter vers une labilisation
d'établissement enseignant euh le
français à l'étranger sans
nécessairement les porter financièrement
mais cela ne doit pas devenir la
principale activité de ces opérateurs on
se
bere souvent on se bere aussi donc
d'illusion lorsque pour présenter des
budgets en équilibre on affiche des
prévisions de ressources propres
irréalistes satisfaisant à court terme
le ministère du budget qui tient
solidement les cortons de la bourse et
le ministère de tutelle qui a mal de
revoir ses ambitions à la baisse mais il
n'y a pas monsieur le ministre hors
quelques opérations de prestige des
jusements énormes de ressources propres
pour les opérateurs et pour le réseau si
l'on exp si l'on accepte les les cours
de langu et trop augmenté les tarifs des
cours de langu a aussi un effort un un
effet sur la fréquentation quant au MES
Sénat il est florissant quant au nos ent
prise se porte bien mais en temps de
crise celles-ci sont confronté aux mêmes
difficultés que l'État est-ce aider les
opérateurs en procédant de la sorte
ainsi le contraire est rude pour les
opérateurs et pour le réseau
elle est démotivante pour les personnels
qui ont besoin d'être professionnalisés
et devoir ouvrir des perspectives de
carrière lors de nos travaux il y a 5
ans nous avions constaté que les
personnels appelés à diriger les centres
culturels ne se voit proposer qu'une
formation de 5 jours à que alors que la
formation initiale euh en Allemagne est
de 6 mois la durée d'immersion dans un
pays euh est relativement courte de
l'ordre de 3 années alors qu'il est de 5
ans pour le British Concil ou pour
l'institut gut enfin l'Allemagne et le
Royaume-Uni offre de bien meilleures
perspectives de carrière aux agents de
leur réseau cultur à
l'étranger dans un rapport dans dans le
rapport
des 5 an nous écrivions déjà la
rénovation de la gestion des ressources
humaines du personnel de notre réseau
culturel à l'étranger do donc être l'une
de nos préoccupations centrales qu'en
est-il de nos objectifs en la matière
avons-nous véritablement progresser je
voudrais aussi souligner monsieur le
ministre l'importance que nous attachons
pour cette pour cette raison au
rattachement du réseau culturel des
établissements à autonomie financière à
l'Institut
français comment imaginer un pilotage de
notre action en ayant d'un côté un
opérateur avec des objectifs de long
terme défini par un contrat plurannuel
d'objectif et de moyen et de l'autre
déconnecter le personnel chargé de la
mise en œuvre il faut monsieur le
ministre que l'administra tion du
ministère se rassure le pilotage par
objectif est souvent plus efficace
qu'une tutelle tatillonne et de court
terme il convient dans cette perspective
de se donner des outils nécessaires à ce
pilotage définir des priorités et non un
catalogue dans le contrat d'objectif et
de moyens à l'Institut français il faut
aussi se doter de moyens d'évaluation et
de contrôle et surtout mettre en place
des équipes bien formées à la commission
des affaires étrangères de la défense et
des forces armées nous devons nous nous
nous nous devons donc particulièrement
être vigilant sur les modalités
d'évaluation de l'expérimentation du
ratachement du réseau culturel à
l'opérateur institut français essayons
de
conforter nos opérateurs et de leur
apporter une continuité dans leur action
et une régularité
pour leur financement la démarche
stratégique du gouvernement doit être
plus explicite et nous nous inquiétons
du pilotage du dispositif existant
nombre d'opérateurs Campus France
l'audiovisuel extérieur de France reste
sans contrat d'objectif les moyens
publics se rétrécissent la capacité
d'évaluation et de et de management au
du ministère nous semble pouvoir être
amélioré et je crois et je sais que
c'est votre volonté monsieur le ministre
je crois qu'il est temps que nous
effuons l'autre bout du
chemin la situation est surtout
d'inviter le le gouvernement mais aussi
nos diplomates et les opérateurs à un
effort de réflex pour redéfinir de façon
plus exigeante nos ambitions et faire de
véritables choix entre les objectifs
mais aussi entre les territoires vers
lesquels nous devons porter nos efforts
en utilisant les leviers les plus
efficaces je suis réaliste je comprends
bien qu'il est difficile de demander des
moyens supplémentaires mais depuis trop
d'années les crédits de l'action
culturelle extérieure sont une trop
facile variable d'ajustement des efforts
peuvent être conduits dans d'autres
secteurs soyez assurés monsieur le
ministre que nous serons attentifs à vos
efforts et nous vous soutiendrons nous
soutiendrons votre action pour Ronner à
notre pays une diplomatie d'influence à
la hauteur de ses
ambitions merci mon cher collègue la
parole à Monsieur André valallini pour
le groupe socialiste pour 7
minutes monsieur le président monsieur
le ministre mes chers collègues le
rayonnement d'un pays dépend nous le
savons tous de multiples facteurs au
premier rang desquels sa culture bien
sûr mais il dépend aussi de sa capacité
d'ouverture sur le monde or aujourd'hui
de nombreux pays font preuve d'une
volonté farouche de promouvoir leur
culture hors de leurs frontières
notamment grâce à l'essort des nouvelles
technologies de la
communication cette explosion de la
diffusion culturelle sur la planète rend
la concurrence de plus en plus vive
notamment dans le domaine de
l'audiovisuel et du
multimédia alors pour que notre culture
continue à rayonner au-delà de nos
frontières il faut bien sûr veiller à
encourager et soutenir sa créativité et
donc sa capacité de production mais
veiller aussi à la promotion et à la
diffusion de cette production pour
atteindre cet objectif l'Audiovisuel
Extérieur de la France peut et doit
jouer un rôle de premier plan en a-t-il
les moyens si le gouvernement a commencé
monsieur le ministre depuis l'été
dernier à remettre de l'ordre dans une
situation qui était devenue inextricable
il reste à valider les objectif assignés
à notre audiovisuel extérieur et surtout
à lui donner les moyens de les mettre en
œuvre cela induit plusieurs
questions première question où en est
l'élaboration du contrat d'objectif et
de moyens de l'aefef et celle du projet
pluriannuel de TV5 Monde de ce contrat
et de ce projet dépend en effet
l'efficacité de notre audiovisuel
extérieur comme outil de notre influence
et donc de notre
rayonnement deuxè question quelle place
le ministère des Affaires étrangères
entend-il jouer en la matière notamment
face au ministère de la Culture qui je
veux le rappeler ici a balayer notre
souhait d'affecter à à l'audiovisuel
extérieur qu petits millions d'euros
issu du supplément de recette de la
redevance au profil de France Télévision
qui en a reçu 50 pour mémoire notre
collègue du gouvernement l'a dit avant
moi l'audiovisuel extérieur ne recevra
donc en 2013 que 314 millions d'euros de
contribution publque soit un peu plus de
8 % seulement des contributions à
l'audiovisuel publ de la France 3e
question quelle stratégie pour les
médias français au Maghreb et au Proche
Orient où chacun connaît le rôle joué
par les chaînes de radio et de
télévision notamment lors des printemps
arabes et où nous constatons aussi
l'influence croissante de certaines
chaînes de télévision du Golfe Persique
ne devrait-on pas développer les médias
en langue arabe pour offrir aux
population l'alternative d'e d'une
information objective et professionnelle
et dépasser la cible traditionnelle des
élites locales afin de toucher une
population plus large pourquoi ne pas
enrichir aussi l'offre radiophonique sur
notre territoire sur le territoire
national par la diffusion de Monte Carlo
doilia sur la bande FM dans certaines
agglomérations de nos grandes villes
notamment face au développement d'une
offre parfois orientée politiquement
mais aussi
religieusement 4è question quelle
utilisation faire de l'Internet aussi
bien dans les médias classiques que dans
les médias spécifiques ou encore de
l'utilisation des réseaux sociaux dans
ce cas l'action audiovisuelle et
l'action culturelle converge largement
ainsi le développement d'une méthode
d'apprentissage du français par le site
internet de de TV5 Monde constitue un
outil utile pour les centres culturels
français à l'étranger cela a été dit
avant moi on peut imaginer aussi la mise
à disposition à travers des opérateurs
spécialisés de livres sous format
électronique ce qui accroîtrait l'offre
culturelle française à un moindre coût
au fur et à mesure de la diffusion des
tablettes numériques sans oublier jamais
que le français est parlé aux quatre
coins du monde et que d'ici 30 ans son
nombre de locuteurs va être multiplié
par 3 pour atteindre 1
milliard monsieur le ministreaction
audiovisuelle extérieure est une
composante importante essentielle de
notre diplomatie d'influence mais aussi
de notre rayonnement nous continuerons
d'y être attentifs je vous
remercie merci mon chers collègues la
parole à madame Claudine Lepage pour le
groupe socialiste pour 6
minutes monsieur le président monsieur
le ministre chers collègues 478
établissements d'enseignement français
dans 130 pays fréquentés par 310000
élèves danst les 2/ers étrangers 101
instituts français 125 antenes
d'institut français et 900 Alliances
françaises dans 161 pays 11 centres ou
instituts francoos nationaux 27 institut
français de recherche à l'étranger 161
services de coopération et d'action
culturelle
10 services pour la science et la
technologie
135 espace Campus France inutile de
poursuivre
l'umération la France possède encore
l'un des réseaux culturels les plus
denses du monde un atout formidable pour
notre pays c'est bien la culture et la
langue française qui font notre force à
l'étranger cette influence douce je
n'ose dire soft power qui contribue ass
Surer à la place de la France dans le
monde et constitue avec notre politique
d'exception culturelle la marque de
fabrique de la diplomatie
française mais depuis plusieurs années
le cœur n'y est plus un profond mal-être
est
apparu certes la présidence Nicolas
Sarkozy a pâti d'une absence de vision
stratégique dans ce domaine essentiel à
cet égard la réforme de l'action
extérieure de l' état en 2010 n'a pas
rempli son objectif le nouvel Institut
français français peine à mettre en
place une politique ambitieuse notamment
en matière de coopération je ne
développerai pas plus avant ce sujet
notre collègue jean Besson l'ayant déjà
traité d'autres vecteurs permettent à la
France de déployer sa culture sa langue
mais aussi ses valeurs sur tous les
continents je pense à la société udovuel
extérieur de la France AEF qui chapote
la 3e radio internationale RFI la chaîne
d'info internationale France24 et Monte
Carlo d'Ilia et je n'oublie pas la
chaîne partenaire TV5 Monde première
chaîne mondiale de télévision en
français André Vallini en a déjà très
bien parlé mais je ne résiste pas à
l'envie d'évoquer la situation de AEF
que je connais particulièrement bien en
ma qualité d'administr administratrice
de cette société et saluer le travail de
la nouvelle présidente Marie-Christine
Saragosse qui en quelques mois a su
redonner espoir aux salariés durement
éprouvé par l'air Sarkozi de pusillac
pour ce qui concerne l'enseignement
français à l'étranger nous revenons
également de loin en effet la prise en
charge des frais de scolarité mise en
place par Nicolas Sarkozy n'a fait
qu'accentuer les inégalités exclure les
familles des classes moyennes mais aussi
les familles étrangères de fait toutes
celles qui ne pouvaient effectivement
pas supporter l'augmentation
phamineuse des coûts de scolarité pour
tous les autres élèves ceux qui ne
bénéficiaient pas de la gratuité et
n'entraient pas dans le cadre
d'attribution des bourses
scolaires dans le souci de redonner à
l'enseignement français à l'étranger ses
objectifs de justice de mixité sociale
mais aussi d'universalité et d'influence
l'une des premières mesures de François
Holland a donc été la suppression de la
PEC je terminerai en évoquant cependant
une inconnue qui demeure quant aux
suites qui seront données à l'arrêt di
Chauvet rendu en mars 2012 par la Cour
administrative d'appel de Paris cette
décision de justice souligne que l'AEFE
a l'obligation dans ses établissements
en gestion directe d'inscrire tout élève
français dont la famille le demande et
seulement une obligation que l'on dit de
moyens pour les enfants non français ces
enfants ne pouvant alors être accueillis
que dans la limite des places
disponibles qui s'entendent alors comme
les places non susceptibles d'être
occupées par les petits
français au côté de ces inconnus
judiciaair il nous faut aussi évoquer la
position de la Commission européenne sur
la nondrimination entre citoyens des
pays membres de l'Union qui si elle se
confirmait induirait de profonds
bouleversements au sein de notre
dispositif d'enseignement français à
l'étranger et de notre système d'aide à
la
scolarité contte tenu de ces différentes
incertitudes je me félicite de la
mission de réflexion et de proposition
sur l'avenir de notre réseau
d'enseignement français à l'étranger
engagé par la ministre déléguée à
laquelle je souhaite bien sûr activement
collaborer nous sommes tous conscients
de la nécessité absolue de réfléchir à
la mise en œuvre d'une nouvelle
politique scolaire à l'étranger capable
de relever les défis auxquels est et
sera confronté notre Réau tout en
maintenant sa double fonction la
scolarisation des enfants français bien
évidemment mais aussi sa mission
d'influence pour avoir encore de futur
Boutros Boutros Gali jodif F ou atiimi
qui fréquente nos établissement et qui
deviennent ambassadeurs de notre langue
et de notre
culture
merci ma chère
collègue la parole à Monsieur Laurent
Fabius ministre des Affaires
étrangères monsieur le président
mesdames et messieurs les sénateurs qui
avvez eu la
patience de rester jusqu'à cette heure
tardive et que je
salue et que je salue avec amitié et
respect je
voudrais procéder de la façon suivante
si vous voulez bien d'un par faire
écho aux interventions des différents
orateurs et ensuite reprendre un propos
plus général pour que personne ne soit
oublié monsieur Duvernois qui connaît
admirablement ces
questions a centré son propos
essentiellement sur l'Institut français
et il porte un jugement positif sur le
travail qui a été fait il a développé
aussi un certain nombre de
considérations sur l'enseignement fra à
l'étranger à
travers ces différentses outils
et il a comme beaucoup d'entre vous
d'ailleurs à juste
titre insisté sur l'importance de
l'audiovisuel extérieur
français insistant sur le soutien dont
celui-ci devait disposer je lui
répondrai bien sûr dans le cours de mon
propos mais je crois que il a mis
l'accent sur les outils principaux il a
fait avec juste raison Madame main de
sailli euh
elle aussi a souligné l'importance du
rayonnement culturel comme vous tous
euh
la nécessité d'avoir une approche
européenne
elle a regretté ce qu'elle a appelé des
coupes
budgétaires même si
certains d'entre vous ont eu le
l'équanimité de le
rappeler chaque ministère est soumis à
ses coupes mais dans la mesure où toute
la partie éducative
euh du ministère des Affaires étrangères
a été exclu de ses coupe cela modère
quand même et module le jugement qu'on
peut porter
elle a insisté sur la francophonie sur
l'if euh a posé une question sur
l'évaluation des Années croisées et
insister elle aussi sur l'audiovisuel
extérieur madame
Laborde a dit avec juste raison me
semble-t-il
que la culture était un investissement
d'avenir
elle a souligné l'importance de la
formation des professionnels
elle a à partir d'un exemple précis mais
beaucoup d'entre vous auraient pu le
reprendre
interrogé pardon sur certain nombre de
restrictions à des visas notamment pour
des professionnels de la culture et je
ne sais pas si vous avez déjà pris
connaissance de la décision que nous
avons adopté avec mon collègue Vals qui
est de rendre c'est une décision que
nous avons rendu publique il y a un ou
de jours qui est de
faciliter les visas
pour toute une série de catégories on
pense aux hommes d'affaires on pense aux
professionnels de la culture et cetera
ce sont des visas qui ne sont pas longs
mais qui permettront de faciliter les
choses et nous avons après avoir étudié
tout cela attentivement envoyer des
instructions à l'ensemble de nos postes
ce qui devrait permettre de résoudre des
questions comme celles qui ont été posé
par Madame labor mais que beaucoup
d'autres d'entre vous auraient pu poser
elle a insisté sur l'action
des collectivités
locales souligner l'importance de la
Convention de l'UNESCO sur la diversité
culturelle et sur ce point je ne vois
pas de différence entre vous et bien
évidemment le Gouvernement partage tout
à fait ces
analyses
madame Blandin
euh à moins que je fasse une confusion
entre madame Laborde et Madame Blandin
ce que
chacune d'entre elles d'un tempérement
très généreux me pardonnerait mais
elle a posé la question comment
dynamiser notre réseau
culturel une question pas facile à
résoudre a été soulevée sur ce que
j'appelle la dialectique entre les
diplommates et les artistes c'est Madame
Laband qui avait fait cela la grande
question est-ce que il faut que ce soit
les artistes qui dirigent les choix
culturels ou est-ce que ce sont les
diplomates et cetera euh je pense ce
n'est pas parce que je suis normand
d'adoption que je vais répondre ainsi
mais que la la bonne réponse est dans un
mélange harmonieux euh bien évidemment
il y a pas d'action culturelle possible
si on ne fait pas appel aux artistes
professionnels mais euh je connais
beaucoup de diplomates qui qui sont
cultivés
euh et je dirais
même que l'immense majorité l'IT et que
ils ont vu arriver avec désolation à
leur tête un ministre qui peut-être
n'avait pas tous les
euh passeport dans ce domaine mais qui
s'y met quand même euh non pour être
sérieux je pense que c'est un bon
brassage un bon mélange entre les uns et
les autres qui permet d'avancer
et puis elle a soulevé plusieurs d'entre
vous l'ont fait ils ont eu raison de le
faire la question de l'accord entre les
États-Unis et l'Europe l'accord de libre
échange la demande instante qu'a faite
le président de la République française
que l'audiovisuel et la culture soi
exclus de cet accord car vous avez vu
peut-être que la Commission spontanément
euh n'avait pas exclu ce domaine et donc
euh la position de la France qui n'est
pas seulement la position de la France
mais qu'il faut je pense soutenir avec
beaucoup de force euh nous avons bien
l'intention de la maintenir dans toute
cette discussion et je crois comprendre
que sur tous les bans du Sénat et ce
sera un atout pour la positionition
française c'est ce même souci
d'exception culturelle de diversité
culturelle qui euh est demandé et qui
doit être préservé
monsieur Beaumont je tâcher là de ne pas
me
tromper
a à la fois souligné que la France était
une puissance qui culturellement compte
mais il a posé la question jusqu'à quand
montrant ainsi son
inquiétude oui l'interrogation est
légitime mais je ne suis pas
pessimiste à faire par profession un
tour du monde à peu près tous les mois
je mesure quand même que nous avons non
seulement un réseau c'est essentiel mais
une influence un rayonnement qui est
reste tout de même exceptionnel
absolument exceptionnel alors bien sûr
il faut faire attention parce que il y a
les contraintes budgétaires parce qu'il
y a vous l'avez tous souligner la
concurrence parce que les nouvelles
technologies nous imposent de changer un
certain nombre de nos méthodes et rendre
possible d'ailleurs euh le maintien et
la préservation de cette puissance mais
euh je crois que il n'y a pas de
fatalité négative en ce domaine et que
la France à condition bien sûr que nous
réfléchissions ensemble que nous
prenions les bonnes décisions peut tout
à fait se maintenir à la pointe avancé
du rayonnement culturel euh monsieur euh
le squarnec a souligné un certain nombre
de points il a au début de son propos
dans une énumération qui était
parfaitement exacte
euh insister sur la place tout à fait
éminente dans le monde de notre réseau
culturel et scolaire mais lui aussi
alors d'une façon peut-être plus
prudente il a dit oui mais attention il
y a un risque de déclin est-ce que notre
langue n'est pas en recul et puis il a
souligné la baisse d'un certain nombre
de crédits il sait que le secteur de
l'enseignement a été complètement
préservé euh j'ai apprécié dans son
propos parce que vraiment c'est une des
questions qui se pose à moi et à nous
tous le fait que comme nous savons qu'il
faut choisir il a euh porté son choix
sur ce qu'il appelle les pays d'avenir
alors bien sûr on peut avoir une
discussion sur quels sont les pays
d'avenir euh et j'imagine que si on
posait cette question à chaque pays peu
d'entre eux répondraient qu'ils ne font
pas partie de cette liste mais vous avez
tout à fait raison et il faut que notre
réseau sur le plan culturel d'ailleurs
comme sur le le plan diplomatique en
général s'adapte euh CIT pas exactement
la même chose le monde de 2010 et il
faut penser plutôt à CELI de 2030 et le
Monde de 1980 et donc je pense que nous
nous retrouverons facilement sur cette
notion euh qui euh euh pense à l'Afrique
grand continent et qui se trouve à être
un continent francophone potentiellement
francophone les chiffres ont été donnés
je crois euh par plusieurs d'entre vous
nous sommes aujourd'hui alors c'est
discuté est-ce que nous sommes 230
millions ou un peu plus de francophones
mais ils ne sont pas discutés pour le
futur euh d'ici une un peu plus d'une
trentaine d'années nous pouvons être
avec le développement de l'Afrique
plutôt 800 millions et voisiner le
milliard donc nous avons cela euh à
opéré et vous avez cher amis insistez
vous aussi sur l'exception culturelle je
compte sur le le rassemblement de tous
les groupes pour nous aider à faire
prévaloir cette notion extrêmement
importante monsieur Christophe André
Frassa dans un propos qui était à la
fois fort et qui comportait beaucoup
d'humour euh c'est désolé de notre recul
d'influence culturel je suis pas aussi
pessimiste que lui d'ailleurs je ne suis
pas sûr qu'il le soit parce que il
connaît bien
les
compatriotes de de l'étranger et il voit
bien même si les choses sont difficiles
que nous gardons quand même une
influence très importante alors oui la
concurrence américaine oui la
concurrence de la Chine bien sûr
mais vous avez souligné aussi cher ami
mais comme si c'était un reproche
l'attractivité des autres pays envers
nos jeunes évidemment s'il s'agissait
d'une fuite de nos jeunes vers les
autres pays ce serait préoccupant et il
faut éviter cet aspect là mais en même
temps il faut se
féliciter évidment c'est toute
l'ambivalence de de du fait que nos
jeunes aillent à l'étranger parce que ce
sont nos
ambassadeurs et ils portent beaucoup
d'espoir là ils ne doivent pas y aller
par beaucoup d'entre vous ont parlé de
l'envie de France par dépit de France
mais il faut se réjouir que nous ayons
beaucoup de Français à l'étranger et
notamment des jeunes et puis ceci est un
autre point sur lequel nous devons tous
nous retrouver il a bien voulu comme
j'avais l'intention de le faire rendre
hommage à la fois à nos diplomates et
aux expatriés donc là nous nous
rejoignons parfaitement Monsieur Jean
Besson qui connaît très bien lui aussi
ces questions euh
à souligné euh la concurrence culturelle
des bricks euh il s'est interrogé sur
les opérateurs nouveaux je pense qu'il
porte un jugement positif mais il dit
attention parce que les moyens sont en
baisse et il soulligne que les gisements
de ressources propres sont limités
limités oui mais pas nul est loin d'être
nul et donc il faut sans considérer que
bien évidemment tout va se faire par
autofinancement euh avoir à l'esprit
quand on voit les trajectoires
budgétaires et il est improbable que
elle devienne
euh spontanément merveilleuse dans les
mois qui viennent euh il faut donc que
nous fassions euh flèche de tout bois
quand à l'Institut français je
reviendrai dans mon propos euh je crois
que c'est un peu tôt encore pour porter
un jugement d'ailleurs vous avez prévu
dans votre sagesse que cette cette année
il y ait un certain nombre de reports
des reports des rapports pardon des
évaluations bon de de choses ont été
faites alors la question c'est extension
pas
extension en tout cas nous avons là le
le début d'élément d'évaluation et je
veux vous en remercier Monsieur Vallini
qui connaît extrêmement bien notamment
les questions audiovisuelles m'a posé
une série de questions je ne suis pas
sûr de pouvoir répondre à toutes donc
prie de bien vouloir m'excuser mais en
tout cas comme il y avait la réponse
dans la question comme souvent
d'ailleurs cela me permettra de
compléter ma mon approche de ces
sujets il a dit et c'est très juste que
l'offre audiovisuelle était renforcée y
compris en France c'est une idée sur
laquelle j'ai demandé aux nouveaux
responsables des différentes chaînes de
travailler parce que c'est très juste
notamment pour euh les chaînes en arabe
alors il y a des questions techniques à
régler qui ne sont pas simples mais bien
évidemment euh les les chaînes qui
diffusent à l'étranger qui sont souvent
de grande qualité on pense à France 24
on pense à TV5 Monde on pense RFI on
pense à Doya et cetera on doit se poser
la question B pourquoi est-ce que on ne
pourrait pas en profiter entre
guillemets euh très largement euh à
intérieur de notre pays et donc nos les
les les personnes qui ont été nommées à
ses responsabilités il travaille
actuellement et puis monsieur valliniier
a insisté à juste titre sur l'importance
des nouvelles technologies pour faire
rayonner notre culture à l'extérieur il
a parfaitement raison enfin Madame Le
Page euh a souligné la densité de notre
réseau français à l'étranger culturel
elle a été euh elle assez critique si
j'ai bien compris de du fonctionnement
de de l'Institut français
elle a décerné la mention bien madame
saragos et euh moi je vous savez comme
dans ces The Voice je je je voterai
aussi je me retourne pour voter aussi
euh euh sans avoir vu ou après avoir vu
enfin de toutes les mes ce qui compte
c'est le choix euh elle a rappelé les
réformes qui est intervenu sur la PEC
d'ailleurs je note que euh finalement
cette réforme qui était importante je
dis pas que c'est qu'elle était facile
mais enfin bon nous sommes là une
dizaine de mois après le chambement de
gouvernement et je n'ai pas entendu que
c'était quand même le souci principal
qui était votre ce qui prouve que vous
avez les uns et les autres bien
travailler et que la réforme
maintenant est passée dans dans dans les
faits et euh vous avez raison de rendre
hommage je le fais aussi à notre
Ministre délégué votre ancienne collègue
madame conouy qui a passé beaucoup de
temps sur ce problème difficile et puis
elle a soulevé madame Le Page une
question que vous connaissez mais dont
la réponse déterminera beaucoup
d'éléments c'estàd qu'il y a des
décisions judiciaires qui sont
intervenues on sais pas exactement euh
la portée qu'elles vont avoir et le
degré d'extension mais si elle devait
avoir une extension maximale elle
remettrait en cause beaucoup de choses
que nous sommes en train de discuter et
nous obligerait bien sûr à reprendre
toute une série euh de ces sujets je
regarde mon petit papier pour voir si
euh dans mon désordre je n'ai pas été
injuste en oubliant tel ou tel orateur
euh je crois que non mais toutes les
manières ce aussi va être complété par
ce que je voulais vous dire euh par
ailleurs
euh je vrais commencer par un souvenir
bon et je pensais à ça lorsque vous
m'avez à l'initiative de Monsieur
Duvernois posé la question le
rayonnement culturel de la France à
l'étranger on a tous un souvenir comme
ça plusieurs même de de de scèn ou de de
d'éléments qui tout d'un coup vous
sauteent au visage ou à la mémoire et
qui rendent évidente la question enfin
la réponse à la question je suis allé il
n'y a pas si
longtemps effectué un périple en
Amérique du Sud
euh successivement au
Panama en Colombie et
euh au Pérou
et en Colombie à
Bokota un matin l'ambassade ur m'a dit
écoutez il y a une cérémonie
traditionnelle dans le lycée
français qui se trouve pas très loin de
l'ambassade alors c'était assez tôt
cétait à 7h du matin je crois mais ma
dit Monsieur le Ministre ser intéressant
quand même que vous veniez voir parce
que c'est quelque chose de qui
qui qui marque je suis arrivé
lycée une cour assez petite et dans cour
il y avait 800
élèves dont la majorité était des
colombien qui était
là alors là-bas il y a l'uniforme en
plus doncon et depuis des petite classe
jusque au classes du bac et qui nous ont
accueilli et
ensuite qui
ont
chanté
dans un français absolument inccable non
pas le premier couplet de la
Marseillaise mais les
cinq premier couplet de la Marseillaise
je ne demanderai pas que l'on fasse
cette exercice dans cette
enceinte
mais non seulement ça voulait dire un
certain nombre de choses sur l'amour de
la France mais sur la culture de la
France sur la maîtrise du français et
quand on voit cela les professeurs étant
là et l'ensemble des beaucoup de parents
d'élèves des représentants du parents
d'élèves on se dit à ce moment-là hein
on est loin de Paris quand même que le
rayonnement culturel de la France ça
n'est pas uniquement un sujet de
discussion c'est vraiment quelque chose
d'extrêmement fort oui la France c'est
une puissance d'influence
euh je n'identifie pas pour ma part on
va pas rentrer dans des querelles de
vocabulaire l'influence et le soft power
je pense qu'il y a trois notions
différentes Monsieur Joseph na qui a
inventé la notion de soft power et de
hard
power on pourrait discuter longuement
sur ces travaux fort intéressants mais
moi je pense que la France est à la fois
une puissance soft et une puissance hard
et que l'ensemble de tout cela fait un
troisème concept qui n'est pas prégence
chez Monsieur na et qui pour moi est une
puissance d'influence l'influence de la
France étant liée à l'ensemble de ces
facteurs et
évidemment notre influence culturelle
fait partie de ce qui constitue notre
puissance d'influence
euh ce rayonnement est une composante
majeure de notre attractivité de notre
image de notre réputation
euh notre dernier prix Nobel monsieur
saroche nous le
rappelle souvent mais lorsque nous
voyons la liste de domed fields lorsque
nous voyons même si ça ser raréfie la
liste de nos prix Nobel de
littérature lorsque nous voyons là ça se
développe la liste de nos
Oscars nos établissements prestigieux
euh en France le Louvre dans sa
diversité mais aussi à l'étranger nos
démembrements la Sorbonne nos écoles de
commerce et leur de membrement
l'Institut Pasteur nos intellectuels nos
écrivains
euh nous avons sans arrogance et sans
crier de
Cocorico une capacité euh de rayonnement
culturel qui est tout à fait remarquable
et ça ne s'applique pas
à nos professions j'allais dire
traditionnelles
seulement nos designers sont connu à
travers le monde nos architectes vous
envoyez les réalisations euh lorsque
vous vous déplacez à
l'étranger nos cinéastes c'est pas un
hasard si nous sommes le premier pays
d'accueil de touristes internationaux
même si je pense personnellement que le
tourisme pourrait donner beaucoup
beaucoup plus de choses qu'il ne donne
en
France Paris n'est pas par hasard la
ville la plus visitée du monde et tout
cela cause et conséquences parce que
c'est un processus dialectique et est à
la fois créateur de culture et en même
temps si je puis dire récepteur de
culture et tout cela vous l'avez soué
n'est pas séparable de l'aspect
économique parce que nos industries
culturelles comptent déjà pour 5 % de
nos exportations et à mon sens pourrait
compter pour beaucoup
plus ce qui signifie
que contribuer à notre rayonnement
culturel linguistique scientifique c'est
un volet très important de notre
politique étrangère qui ne dépend pas
bien sûr que de l'État qui dépend de
beaucoup d'autres éléments mais à tous
les niveaux comme responsablebl
politique nous avons une mission
essentielle d'appui et le ministère des
Affaires étrangères a pour tâche de
promouvoir cette culture à l'étranger de
développer nos échanges de défendre
notre modèle dans les enceintes
multilatérales et les discussions
bilatérales pour cela là nousous
appuyons sur un réseau
exceptionnel je pas rappeler les
chiffres que vous avez donné simplement
je voudrais à cette occasion rendre
hommage à tous ceux et à toutes celles
qui le font vivre c'est pas simplement
un héritage ou une situation acquise
comme vous l'avez souigné il y a une
compétition pour l'influence elle est
extrêmement rude pas seulement avec les
très grands pays le Royaume-Uni vous les
avez vous l'avez cité c'est British
Council l'Allemagne avec notamment
l'Institut
G qui outre le fait d'apprendre
l'allemand m'a personnellement mise en
contact avec ma première fiancée donc à
ce titre évidemment je ne peux que
saluer avec une part de
nostalgie l'efficacité de cet institut
le
Japon qui s'est doté en
1972 d'une fondation du Japon l'Espagne
avec le réseau servantè et puis d'autres
acteurs on cite toujours la Chine qui
pour ne parler qu'elle que d'elle
produit si je peux employer cette
expression par an combien de diplômé
universitair je donne la réponse 6
millions par 6
millions il faut donc de notre part une
action extrêmement forte pour développer
notre rayonnement c'est pas simplement
la promotion de la culture et la langue
française
mais c'est beaucoup plus large et c'est
la raison pour laquelle ça a été
souligné dans la même direction de mon
ministère il y a la coopération
culturelle universitaire et de la
recherche pour prendre ces différents
aspects de politique d'influence quels
sont nos objectifs beaucoup d'entre vous
ont demandé quels sont nos objectifs ben
il y en a deux ou trois le premier c'est
de promouvoir la création française et
le patrimoine français dans tous les
domaines ça veut dire l'écit musique les
arts plastiques les arts de la scène le
cinéma l'architecture le design et on
pourrait
augmenter je lis patrimoine et
créations la mission prioritaire de
notre réseau culturel c'est de
promouvoir notre culture notre langue
nos créateurs là où comme vous les avez
souligné tout à l'heure se construit le
monde de demain et où notre présence
n'est pas nécessairement spontanée j'ai
parlé de l'Afrique mais on doit parler
aussi de l'Amérique latine de l'Asie
notre image est souvent spontanément
positive il y a une tradition
francophile je pense à l'Amérique latine
où nous sommes très aimés alors certains
qui ont le goût du paradoxe mais comme
disait Jean-Jacques Rousseau ce n'est
pas une paradoxe automatiquement une
vérité si nous sommes aimés c'est pas
parce que nous sommes absents je pense
que c'est quoi que nous soyons absents
et donc il absent ou insuffisamment
présent rien n'est acquis il faut que
nous travaillons sur ces pays euh pour
cela il faut que nous travaillons
notamment en partenariat avec les
grandes institutions culturelles euh ça
na pas été cité dans la discussion mais
vous l'aviez toutes à l'esprit nos
grands musées Orset
pontpidou branl le Louvre Abou Dhabi ce
sont des réalisations des projets qui
sont des vitrines extraordinaires de la
France nous devons soutenir la création
français dans toute sa diversité que ce
soit des artistes ou des créateurs déjà
établis je va pas donner une liste parce
que il n'y a pas de hiérarchie à opérer
mais en matière d'œuvres soit de
peinture ou de sculpture en matière de
balai en matière de cinéma en matière
d'architecture il faut à la fois
soutenir les talents établis et puis la
génération montant nous agissons
également en faveur de la promotion des
industrie culturelle et créative
française ça représente 350000 emplois
et lorsque lorsqu'on dit que ça
représente l'audiovisuel le cinéma le
livre notre rôle consiste à la fois à
soutenir ces industries dans leur
promotion à l'internationale à défendre
la spécificité des biens culturels pour
que nous maintenions la créativité et la
diversité de ces secteurs nous y serons
vigilants je l'ai dit dans le cadre des
négociations en vue d'un accord entre
les États-Unis et l'Europe il faut être
particulièrement attentif au secteur de
l'édition française euh qui est la
première de nos industries culturelles
par son poids économique et dont 25 % du
chifre d'affaires réalisé à
l'international les enjeux liés aux
négociations européennes et
internationales sont majeurs les
éditeurs du Syndicat national de
l'édition que j'ai rencontré récemment
pour le Salon du livre ont soué à quel
point ils étaient attentifs à cet aspect
et à la liberté de publier dans le monde
nous devons veiller aussi à la diffusion
d'un regard français sur le monde
l'influence passe par des canaux
multiples mais le rayonnement vous
l'avez souigné est très lié à
l'audiovisuel
en 2015 le nombre de chaînes télévisées
qui émettent dans le monde sera de plus
de
3000 il est donc fondamental que la
France ait toute sa place dans cette
société des médias c'est la mission que
Madame philippetier moi-même avons
confié à la nouvelle direction de
l'Audiovisuel Extérieur de la France
nous avons des chaînes vous les regardez
quand vous êtes à l'étranger qui sont de
très bonne qualité TV5 Monde 235
millions de foyers France 24 qui est
désormais je crois bien implanté dans le
paysage d'échîn internationale
d'information
RFI qui est une des radios
internationales les plus écoutées
notamment enAfrique et Monte Carlo Doya
nous avons là des atouts majeurs il y a
eu ce que j'appelleraiis publiquement
des
turbulences les choses nous semblent
àaisé une réflexion est en cours dans le
cadre des discussions sur le nouveau
contrat d'objectif et de moyens de la EF
pour pour obtenir la meilleure
adaptation possible de notre dispositif
audiovisuel extérieur à l'évolution des
enjeux internationaux avec une attention
particulière aux spectateurs auditaires
des zones jugé prioritaire le pôle média
de l'AEF c'est ce que demande monsieur
Vallini sera renforcé et nous assumons
totalement le rôle stratégique qui est
le nôtre et le ministère des Affaires
étrangères entend jouer totalement son
rôle parce que c'est vraiment un outil
majeur un deuxème axe prioritaire c'est
la francophonie la francophonie c'est un
atout énorme qui quelquefois
insuffisamment apprécié en France je dis
parfois pour plaisanter est-ce que c'est
vraiment une plaisanterie que le
français devrait être développé partout
dans le monde y compris en France
et c'est vraiment quelque chose sur
lequel il faut
insister nous voulons miser sur la
francophonie pas seulement parce que
c'est une langue que nous avons un
partage mais parce que la francophonie
porte un certain nombre de valeurs elle
permet de faciliter les échanges elle a
un impact économique
positif je crois que c'est vous monsieur
duver qui faisiez allusion à cette étude
qu'on m'a montré sur laquelle les
échanges commerciaux induit par
l'appartenance à l'espace francophone se
sont traduit ces dernières années par un
supplément de PIB par tête de 6 % en
moyenne dans les pays concernés serait
d'ailleurs intéressant je sais pas si on
l'a fait de faire passer cette étude à
nos collègues qui montre que la
francophonie c'est pas une vieille lune
c'est quelque chose qui est devant nous
et qui de tous les points de vue
culturel économique et des valeur a un
rôle positif la francophonie c'est pas
simplement la France nous sommes
co-créateurs de la Francophonie avec
beaucoup d'autres pays nous avons mis
sur pied avec eux un plan d'action
consolider la famille des pays
francophones en partiul en Afrique et
dans les pays
arabes renforcer l'enseignement du
français dans les pays non francophones
promouvoir le français dans la vie
internationale national et de ce point
de
vue-là puisque les propos qu'ontient à
cette tribune sont
reproduits je ne trouve pas absolument
indispensable lorsque une assemblée
totalement francophone est réunis que
les responsables s'expriment en anglais
euh car d'une part en général ils ne
rendent pas un grand service à l'anglais
car cet anglais est à peu près
approximatif mais d'autre part imaginez
et c'est pas d'imagination c'est un
savoir réel que vous ayez en face de
vous tel ou tel compatriote enfin non
pas compatriote tel ou tel collègue
francophone d'un autre pays qui a passé
des années des années à apprendre le
français qui le parle dans un milieu
parfois hostile et il entend les
dirigeants à la tribune francophone
parfait francophone parfois même
français commencer à s'exprimer en
anglais non ne soyons pas non plus
Chauvin
bon l'anglais est eu une langue outil
euh comme l' euh l'informatique bon
quand je dis l'anglais c'est l'Américain
car je pas faire une grande injure à nos
collègues britanniques pensez que si
l'anglais n'était parlé qu'en
Grande-Bretagne il aura une influence
plus limitée de ce point de vue je vous
cite une anecdote je ne sais pas si euh
vous la connaissez mais elle a une
vérité historique et elle vous permettra
de servir d'introduction à propos devant
une assemblée francophone euh savez-vous
que lorsque les États-Unis d'Amérique
ont eu à choisir leur langue il y avait
trois langues qui étaient en conférence
il y avait le français il y avait
l'anglais et il y avait
l'allemand l'allemand n'a pas obtenu
beaucoup de souffrage et l'anglais ce
qui n'est pas évident pour les
États-Unis compte tenu des rapports
entre le colonisateur et colonisé
l'anglais ne l'a emporté que de une voix
et comme la République oui et l'histoire
dit que deux euh des votants sont
arrivés en retard qui avait l'intention
paraî-il de voter pour le français alors
je laisse à penser ce qu'aurait été la
francophonie si ces deux retardataires
je fa pas allusion à Monsieur Longuet
qui vient de nous rejoindre si ces deux
retardataires et que je salut si ces
deux retardata étai arrivés à l'heure en
tout cas je reviens à mon propos parce
que j'ai légèrement dévié pour la
francophonie l'enseignement du français
est absolument décisif il s'appuie sur
un réseau magnifique d'établissement
scolaire
euh l'opérateur l'Agence pour
l'enseignement français à l'étranger
l'opérateur de l'État la Mission laïque
française on connaît tout ça le label
France éducation a été lancé en 2012 et
je pense que c'est une bonne chose il
encourage le développement d'un
enseignement bilingue francophone
d'excellence à l'étranger et le réseau
d'établissement à l'étranger c'est
vraiment un atout que je veux et que
nous voulons je crois tous développer
madame conouet va me faire des
propositions pour son renfercement non
pas de Madame conou mais de
l'enseignement à l'étranger elle me
rendra son rapport au mois de juin après
qu'elle aura procédé à une large
consultation des acteurs de la
communauté éducative française à
l'étranger cette réflexion prendra en
compte les conséquences possibles
madame LEP en parla des développements
juridiques exercice important et si vous
le voulez bien vous y serez associer
pour donner votre opinion cette mission
fait également suite à la suppression de
la prise en charge des droits de
scolarité à l'étranger on en a parlé je
pense qu'il est pas utile d'y revenir
simplement vous savez que sa suppression
é la première étape d'une réforme plus
globale d'aide à la
scolarité et nous allons donc progresser
dans le même sens 3è priorité
attractivité pour les étudiants et les
chercheurs étrangers euh
oui je reviens un petit peu en arrière
une fois que la mission de Madame conou
aura eu lieu il y aura un contrat
d'objectif et de moyen qui sera conclu
avec la EFE c'est une question qui a été
posée donc j'y réponds 3ème priorité
dernière priorité attractivité pour les
étudiants les chercheurs étranger c'est
un élément essentiel de notre
rayonnement qui passe par la promotion
de l'enseignement supérieur français
l'amélioration de l'accueil des
étudiants et des chercheurs étrangers et
la mobilisation de nos scientifiques
partout où se créent des normes où se
développent des idées ou se forment des
élit euh c'est la mission confiée
notamment à Campus France je crois que
monsieur baaon avait posé question
là-dessus et donc je réponds à Monsieur
baumon que le contrat d'objectif et de
moyens devrait être conclu avant l'été
donc là aussi vous serez
consultter pour que les choix soient
pertinents nous travaillons avec le le
ministère de l'Éducation a renforcé le
lien entre Campus France et les
universités le qu d'Orsay en appui de ce
dispositif finance beaucoup de bourses
pour permettre à des étudiants et jeunes
chercheurs à potentiel élevé de
poursuivre leur cursus en France il y a
une contrainte budgétaire mais malgré
cela nous avons maintenu les crédits
alloués aux bourses étudiantes pour
soutenir la destination France nous
avons je dois le dire j'espère que je ne
fâcherai personne en disant cela nous
avons abranché la circulaire géant parce
que elle nous paraissait indépendamment
d'autres considérations ne pas
comprendre exactement ce que va être le
monde de demain le monde de demain c'est
un monde ouvert où nous avons besoin de
brassage et c'est un immense euh atout
euh pour la France d'avoir des étudiants
étrangers qui viennent chez nous qui se
forment ils peuvent avoir un premier
emploi en France et ensuite quand ils
reviennent chez eux ce sont les
meilleurs ambassadeurs de la culture
française et donc je je pense que cette
circulaire qui été prise sans doute pour
d'autres raisons n'était
pas ne procédait pas d'une vision
moderne du monde et je pense que nous
avons eu tout à fait raison de la
supprimer d'entrée de jeu nous voulons
attirer la mobilité étudiant 300000
étudiants
étrangers parce que ça répond aux
besoins de nos écoles qui doivent
demeurer dans le peloton de tête
d'économie de la connaissance ce sont
aussi les besoins de nos entreprises qui
se tournent vers ses étudiants qualifiés
pour développer leurs activités
internationales vous avez tous
l'expérience de ces entreprises qui
disent ben voilà il y a tel ou tel
étudiant étranger on va le prendre il
est excellent donc il faut aller dans ce
sens-là et c'est une immense force de
pouvoir accueillir chez nous ces
étudiantes ces étudiants qui se forment
et puis ensuite qui vont retourner le
moment venu dans leur pays il faut avoir
cette idée en tête de la même façon que
vous avez tous dit qu'il y avait une
concurrence mais la concurrence ça ne
peut pas consister à se refermer sur
soi-même et euh j'ai dit que nous sommes
en train de travailler avec euh monsieur
valalls pour euh voir comment on pouvait
euh préciser les conditions d'accueil
des étudiants étrangers sur notre
territoire pour tenir notre r dans la
compétition internationale faisons
attention à ceci c'est notre sujet est
un peu en dehors du sujet euh dans toute
politique de visa il y a deux aspects et
non pas un seul il y a évidemment une
politique euh migratoire euh euh je
crois que c'était ich rard qui avait dit
une formule célèbre et cetera B que tout
le monde a à l'esprit bon et bien sûr on
ne peut pas avoir frontière ouvertes à
l'égard de la totalité du monde donc il
y a une politique migratoire dans les
visas mais il y a aussi une dimension
d'attractivité et il est évident que
vis-à-vis de toute une série de
populations au pluriel nous devons avoir
une pratique qui soit beaucoup plus
rapide beaucoup plus pertinente que
celle que nous avons eu dans le passé je
pense que si on on distingue politique
migratoire et attractivité si on a
l'esprit qu'il y a ces deux facettes à
ce moment-là on peut avoir une politique
adaptée l'accent mis sur l'attractivité
de notre pays pour les talents est
indissociable d'une réflexion sur les
visas nous voulons que la France
devienne le pays de ceux qui développent
des échanges qui participent à la
recherche qui contribuent à l'effort de
création artistique combien d'entre nous
je dis d'entre nous parce que nous
sommes j'allais dire même si aujourd'hui
c'est peut-être plus facile pour moi de
délivrer des visas que pour vous mais
nous sommes dans la même situation
euh nous avons eu des des des festivals
où il y a tel artiste qui peut venir et
puis tel autre qui doit l'accompagner
alors c'est pas possible parce que il
n'a pas eu de visa et cetera bon ce sont
des j'allais dire des sautises qui
donnent de la France une image négative
alors qu'il faut avoir une vision
finalement beaucoup plus adapté ça
peut-être des hommes d'affaires des
universitaires des scientifs des
artistes des touristes madame Blandin a
insisté avec raison là-dessus qui ont la
France pour destination privilégié et
donc nous avons donné avec Manuel Vals
une instruction réseau diplomatique et
consulaire d'améliorer partout c'est
possible le taux de délivrance des visas
qu'on appelle visas de circulation c'est
cours séjour et leur durée de validité
ces visas permettront notamment leur
titula d'entrer et de sortir à plusieurs
reprises de l'espace Schengen sans être
contraint de demander un nouveau visa à
chaque déplacement cette politique
nouvelle est équilibrée elle répond d'un
côté aux exigences de maîtrise des
fluxatoires et des enjeux de sécurité et
de l'autre à la volonté d'accroître
l'attractivité de notre pays et ce sont
des sujets dont vous aurez sûrement à
parler avec Monsieur Vals et nous
travaillons nous continuons à travailler
ensemble je pense que c'est ainsi en
dépassionnant le débat qu'on peut
arriver à faire des choses intéressantes
nous mettons également en œuvre en
concertation avec le ministère compétent
et les autres acteurs français une
stratégie cohérente de diplomatie
scientifique avec des outil comme le
réseau des insstitut Français de
recherche à l'étranger qui développe une
coopération scientifique d'excellence en
sciences humaines et sociales avec nos
partenaires les missions de fouille
archéologique à l'étranger qui
approfondissent notre connaissance de
l'histoire des pays concernés et les
programmes de recherche pour le
développement qui contribuent à la
constitution de capacités de recherche
au sud alors évidemment si on veut
relever ces défis j'en ai donné trois et
puis il y a tout ce que vous avez dit
notre dispositif doit tenir compte des
évolutions du monde premier chantier
modernisation du réseau culturel nous
devons évidemment participer à la
maîtrise des dépenses publiques euh nous
avons déjà vous l'avez souligné
contribué beaucoup à cet effort en terme
d'effectif ou de moyens financiers mais
euh nous devons bien nous définir si
nous voulons euh faire les choses utiles
c'est un pque de fixer nos priorités
géographiques et stratégiques tout en
développement des méthodes de travail
nouvelles les services vont me faire des
propositions de redéploiement pertinent
des ressources pour accompagner
l'émergence de pays ou de région du
monde devenu en pas devenir des pays
prescripteurs
s'agit pas de négliger le rayonnement de
la France dans des pays qui sont les
partenaires traditionnels on peut penser
à l'Allemagne à l'Italie mais nous
devons projeter aussi notre pays dans
d'autres zones à très fort potentiel où
se trouvent de plus en plus les enjeux
de l'influence internationale les grands
émergents la Chine l'Inde le Brésil mais
aussi d'autres pays d'Asie d'Amérique
latine ou d'Afrique il nous faut
répondre il faut répondre à ce que vous
appelez le désir de France et même le
susciter nous devons aussi mieux
coordonner nos missions notamment avec
l'action extérieure des collectivités
territorial avec l'action des grandes
ONG de la société civile nous devons
coordonner aussi notre action au niveau
européen pour lever des financement
communautaire monter des opérations
conjointes par exemple au sein du réseau
qui rassemble les agences culturelles
européennes et de